hoge leute da bin ich wieder habt ihr gestern ohne mich überlebt gestern morgen es gab ja
kein aufwachen stream gestern ja ja schrecklich konnte nicht aufwachen das dachte ich mir
dachte mir schon das dass da manche probleme haben ich konnte gestern nicht es ist nichts
schlimmes gewesen oder so ich bin wandern gegangen weil es schönes wetter war und es die letzten
tage so scheißwetter war und habe ich mir gedacht gut so paar stunden draußen rumlaufen
ist war wichtiger als stream schon das richtige wlan gefunden für was das besteht sich garantiert
auf irgendwas was ich letztens erzählt habe aber ich habe keine ahnung was es ging ja
ja wandern achso nee nee nee nee tweet von letzter woche achso das dass ich irgendwelche
wlan suchen soll ja da habe ich alle gefunden ja es aber das war wieder typisch typischer
wahnsinn ich sollte ich weiß kriegst gar nicht mehr genau zusammen ich sollte irgendwelche
wlan raussuchen wusste ich wo es steht kannst mal dein autostell machen ja mache ich wanderstream
mit deutschem denn ja klar weißt ihr was leute irgendwann mache ich das irgendwann machen
wir mal wanderstream da fahre ich hier auf irgendein berg oder so weil mein berg ist
jetzt für die schweizer und die ja und die bayer und die österreicher und so ist es
ja hier nix 480 meter oder so das ist ja da sagen die omega lul ich hatte irgendwo eigentlich
auch mal wenn man es braucht ja ja ja ne ne ne das ist für die leute alle kein kein berg
ja ja da bin ich mir das klar neiko moin erste nachricht massive chat action hier ich
hatte heute kein vorstellungsgespräch aber ich habe mich ausgetauscht über neuen job
zu witziger weise gestern wo ich das video hochgeladen habe hat sich quasi noch während
die premiere lief per mail ein ehemaliger kollege wurden gemeldet dort dort wo ich also
von dort wo ich gerade noch arbeite der ist vor einer weile weg woanders hin hat gemeint
max wir suchen noch leute beziehungsweise er sucht noch leute weil er jetzt wohl irgendwie
sich dort als teamleiter versuchen will mal gucken zumindest mich macht das ja insofern
zuversichtlich dass ich muss wenn ich im stream sage ich suche was oder im video sage ich
suche was ohne dass ich irgendwas mache melden sich immer die leute also insofern was passiert
dann erst wenn man wirklich mal anfängt aktiv zu suchen hat man dann an einem tag acht angebote
oder was wenn schon so random einfach immer welche rein purzeln also leute ich will ja
eigentlich gar nicht so gar nicht richtig weg da wo ich bin aber erstens liegt das daran
weil ich faul bin zwar in zwar die leute mag aber dass das dritte ist weshalb ich wahrscheinlich
doch abhauen werde die erzählen halt immer dass sie sich verbessern werden aber es passiert
halt nichts und 31 der zwölfte ist wahrscheinlich stichtag umso war 2.0 was ist damit die bahn
die bahn hat sogar gar keine so schlechten stellen aber ich hasse die bahn ich meine
ich könnte bei der bahn arbeiten aber auch nur mit 100 prozent home office dann habe
ich keine probleme mit da kann ich das machen weil ich fahre bestimmt nicht mit der bahn
zur bahn ins büro korrekt die labern immer viel wenn der tag lang ist home office 2.0
youtube video wollte ich dann ja ich nee dazu wollte ich nichts mehr machen ich glaube
ich wollte mal heim automatisierungstechnisch was zeigen ja heim automatisierungstechnisch
wollte ich was zeigen nichts nicht mein homeserver der homeserver habe ich schon gezeigt ja aber
du hast aber du hast vollkommen recht die erzählen so viel wenn der tag lang ist wenn
ich mir überlege ich glaube ich glaube ich habe euch das schon ein paar mal gesagt aber
ich habe bei ganz vielen verbesserungs vorschlägen dinger bei mir auf der arbeit mitgemacht
ja es gab mal sogar einmal am wochenende sogar einmal am wochenende gut das wurde einem dann
einmal zum glück mit mit arbeitszeit bezahlt letztendlich aber wir hatten mal so ein app
innovations innovations app wettbewerb da wir ein app prototyp entwickelt und ja das
war komplett also letztendlich haben wir unsere idee hat gewonnen aber nicht von uns irgendwelche
anderen dudes haben unsere app idee geklaut haben aber keine app kein app prototyp gebaut
im prototyp workshop sondern haben einfach nur eine geile präsentation gebaut ohne den
prototyp und wir waren halt so doof und haben das gemacht was was eigentlich gedacht war
nämlich ein mini prototyp als als pwr gebaut ja gut was auch immer das war auch schon geil
dass sie da gewonnen haben komplett am thema vorbei aber random naja zumindest da habe
ich mitgemacht dann habe ich noch mal auf irgendwelchen anderen größeren veranstaltungen mitgemacht
mit verbesserungsvorschlägen und was meint ihr unterm strich leute ich ich habe da jetzt
über zehn jahre immer mal wieder verbesserungsvorschläge eingebracht auch wirklich an stellen die explizit
gesagt haben sie wollen verbesserungsvorschläge und sie sagen ja auch immer aber man soll
sich ja immer hinterfragen bla bla bla was meint ihr wie viel von dem was ich vorgeschlagen
habe was geworden ist beziehungsweise was rausgekommen ist oder ich wenigstens was gehört habe nix
ja genau so sieht es aus nix nix das einzige was passiert manchmal wenn man gar so sehr
meckert man hat den scheiß selbst an der backe zum beispiel auch so ein geiles thema sie
hatten bei uns mal die idee die leute sollten zukünftig über über zytrex arbeiten anstatt
vpn und da habe ich habe ich mit einem zusammen mal präsentation gehalten und wo wir weiß
ich auch mal das präsentation nennen kann weil das war eigentlich eine mecker präsentation
wo wir mal gezeigt haben dass es halt einfach nicht geht über zytrex browser zytrex oder
wie zytrex wie die coolen leute das sagen keine ahnung zytrex zytrex zumindest es funktioniert
halt nicht und vor allem browser laggy as fuck haben wir gezeigt haben wir gemacht haben
alle verstanden das ist eine wie nennt sich das eine wie heißt das remote infone vm infrastructure
wie nennt sich das denn im prinzip nee nee nee nee nicht remote desktop das heißt es
hat auch so einen speziellen namen vdi genau puckel das meine ich vdi virtual desktop infrastructure
ist das glaube ich also sprich du hast ein arbeits dein dein dein dein arbeitsrechner
ist quasi nur noch über ein browser oder über ein extra client erreichbar und läuft
irgendwo anders ist halt laggy wie sau ja es war für den arsch sondern haben wir gezeigt
guck mal hier das verschluckt copy und paste und es backt dort rum und es ist hier und
es ist kacke und wo ist das jetzt am ende drauf rausgelaufen wir sollen uns jetzt selbst
drum kümmern also ich habe gemerkt hat und jetzt soll ich selbst machen so nach dem motto
da habe ich mir gedacht wisst ihr was das war das allerletzte mal dass ich irgendwas
erzählt habe und vorgeschlagen habe in der richtung ja ja ja mache ich ich will sehr
viel zeug muss noch gemacht werden aber ich kann nicht alles gleichzeitig machen
brauche mal kurz etwas erheitenderes wartet mal kurz oh nee nee das ist auch zu
die die shop musik jetzt auch nicht das hat man auch gerade ja so war so was geht auch
du du du du du das ist nicht enterprise genug dass wir das verwenden aber es ist auch laggy
as fuck alles generell sind remote des tops laggy as fuck wenn es die traditionelle variant
ist das einzige was geht sind quasi so game gaming beziehungsweise games streaming sachen
wenn man die dafür verwendet so parcel zum beispiel oder shadow soll auch ganz ok sein
die halt so eine die halt nicht einfach nur sinnlos das bild von irgendeiner vm rüber kopieren
sondern halt wirklich super effizient den grafikkarten output abgreifen und und rüber
schicken mit irgendwas speziell also gibt es ein paar sachen aber irgendwie ist das
noch nicht im business bereich angekommen kann das verwenden aber es gibt irgendwie
die business lösung sind immer schrott sind fast alle schrott ja auch wie gesagt kann
ich kann ich also als nächstes als nächstes kommt tatsächlich noch ein battlefield video
bevor modern warfare released weil die haben ihr orbital überarbeitet dazu muss ich mich
noch mal auslassen also im prinzip sie haben ein paar kisten platziert wobei orbital haben
sie anscheinend am meisten überarbeitet in orbital gibt es eine komplett neue flagge
und einen tunnel wo man rein kann ja und im nächsten battlefield video gibt es da noch
eine runde sell out die discord mods konnten den sellout schon hören und die haben gesagt
dass das geht das geht das geht noch monotoner
blazingly fast und es geht nicht um das kann nicht sein dass das schließt sich aus blazingly
fast und nicht um rastus geht nicht nur rastus blazingly fast
keine ahnung ja und das war natürlich selbstverständlich das letzte battlefield video was sonst ganz
schön sehr laut nene komisches mobile game das ist auch so ein ding alter das ist richtig
richtig cringe was ich also massive kürze was ich da wieder erzählen muss
da sind setze dabei wo ich mich immer die frage wer schreibt wer schreibt diese diese
scripts moment ich lese euch mal einen satz vor sekunde ich lese euch mal einen satz vor
da bist du moment wo habe ich das kippe kurz in die pens gucken ja der desktop der ist
ein exzellenter desktop desktop ist ein ordner wie alles andere auch also hier wo habe ich
es denn entdecke genieße schnelle und witzige spiele ne wo ist es denn hier hört euch mal
diesen satz an leute also ich frage mich wer diese scripts immer schreibt entdecke deine
bett eifere seite und spiele turniere um epische preise zu gewinnen bett eifere seite was
so wer schreibt diese texte immer man aber um epische preise zu gewinnen moin so ich
muss mal kurz hier das keine ahnung ich update mal kurz meine kiste für basteln heute was
kleines obi wait a minute es gibt kein update start der server kaputt wie sie laut bomb
bomb battlefield jetzt wieder nicht laut so nur postman gibt es ein update nicht post
woman postman doch und dann erzähle ich aber was wir heute machen sollten wir heute auf
die reihe kriegen wenn ich nicht gar so sehr wahrscheinlich kriegen wir es nicht ich kenne
mich wahrscheinlich kriegen wir es nicht auf die reihe also nächste battlefield video
kommen dann die tage noch wahrscheinlich 26 weil 28 da ist mw2 release da muss dann
ein tag später was zu erzählen und da gibt es eine runde sellout dabei und das nächste
ist auch schon geplant also das nächste video mit sellout ist auch schon geplant das ist
tatsächlich was was ich ganz gut finde da muss ich ja noch was zu sagen wenn es soweit
ist ja und was habe ich verpasst war irgendwas spannendes chat irgendwelchen high IQ sachen
ach so ja wisst ihr dass microsoft jetzt einen eigenen cc cleaner hat ich reboot immer
weiß man weiß er hier nie kam einmal reboot microsoft hat jetzt einen eigenen ein eigenes
tool für windows zum aufräumen hier der microsoft pc manager cleaner tool für windows jetzt
passt mal auf wenn man das runterladen will passt mal auf sieht super vertrauenserwürdig
aus oder die schiller chinesen sind überall man überall und das ist eine offizielle microsoft
seite das ist kein scam guck das ist offizielle microsoft seite es sieht aber nicht so aus
wie was was ich mir runterladen will man hat mich google nicht eben gefragt ob ich auf
englisch übersetzen will die seite ist problem wenn man es auf englisch übersetzt die räumen
per remote desktop aus ja microsoft hat es per funny fiverr in the out gesourced die
räumen an ein rechner auf remote leute was jetzt eine vm ist kaputt
was ist das hintergrundbild eigentlich keine ahnung das ist bing image of the day ich erkenne
nicht was es ist ist das so so mandala mäßig oder sowas was ist das sand reis etwas an
dungeon kieber wie die debian sekte vmw warum ist denn jetzt mein warum geht denn hier
mein mein mein der bildschirm immer moment ja alles klar aus irgendwelchen gründen ist
der vmw service abgekackt soll mir recht sein moment etsch ne get wallpaper excellent jetzt
geht das was wir machen einfach mal alles wieder aus und es war die home assistant vm
an die braunwolle nehme ich dazu zack welches betriebssystem ist das das ist man jaro mit
i3 wm man man manch einer würde jetzt sagen es ist ein arch linux aber es ist kein richtiges
arch linux weil echtes arch linux ist nur arch linux und dementsprechend ist es auch
nicht bei the way man jaro und auch nicht arch bei the way sondern es ist nur man jaro
weil was jetzt geht das alter was ist denn jetzt los kann es mal auf bleiben hier vielleicht
oder hat sich das gerade geupdatet dass man jaro mit i3 wm die config ist auf github die
ist ein bisschen älter aber groß und ganz ist es immer noch so check for updates gibt
keine updates ja hier wollte uns microsoft scam mit der china chinesen seite keine ahnung
warum es das überhaupt gibt ich mein man könnte ja anstatt sein extra cleaning tool
anzubieten einfach die sachen in windows einbauen ja ist irgendwie ein bisschen kaputt weiß
auch nicht was jo ja hat bei mir auch geholfen jetzt ich weiß nicht was es hat habe das
eigentlich eingestellt dass das automatisch geht beziehungsweise sogar noch mal am startup
vom desktop aber anscheinend wollte er nicht doch ich erzähle euch jetzt mal was wir heute
machen und zwar fange ich jetzt am besten an erst mal die passende atmosphäre dafür
schaffen das eiken ist auch etwas etwas oder übrigens in diesem terminal ist es kaputt
der das ascii aquarium funktioniert eigentlich nur im x-traum richtig da ist nämlich auch
die burg da unten und so was die gibt die gibt es hier nämlich gar nicht guck die burg
ist broken das ist das ist nicht sway das ist richtig richtig echtes i3 nicht whale
and crap weil nicht das x weniger crappy ist aber x funktioniert wenigstens ordentlich
in der vm whale and cancer knicken weil er geht noch nicht mal copy paste und wisst ihr
was das geilste ist an whale in der vm der screen refresh nicht mal also du hast quasi
echte null fps mit whale in der vm also also jetzt versuche ich euch mal zu erklären was
ich was ich machen will und zwar ihr wisst ja ich verwende home assistant für meine
heim automatisierung so das ding hier zum beispiel da ist nicht an home assistant 32
ach nee hier 32 excellent ja ich verwende hier home assistant für meine heim automatisierung
das ist jetzt nur eine testkiste jetzt gell nicht dass irgendjemand denkt das ist mein
echtes und ich liege hier was und so was das ist nur für nur für ein stream hier welche
programmier sprachen kannst du ich hatte dann irgendwo mal ein
was immer das ist ok ich habe keine ahnung mehr ich hatte da die musik ist wieder auf
einmal die können sich entscheiden oder jetzt ist die musik wieder laut eben war die musik
leise schlecht schlecht abgemischte playlist pepega playlist also ich hatte mal irgendwo
irgendwie jetzt das gilt oder so roggers vielleicht da da habe ich ein paar sachen mal aufgeschrieben
ok das ist aber nicht das was ich eigentlich gesucht habe also fangen wir mal an machen
wir das mal machen wir das mal irgendwie also da lassen wir überlegen dort netzey sharp
kann ich relativ gut kobold kann ich minimal kobold haben wir mal im stream gemacht aber
ich kann immerhin zwei zeilen kobold programmieren was heute die wenigsten leute können go ist
ganz passabel minimal rust geht halbwegs php geht so ein bisschen power shell ganz ok groovy
das ist die einzige sprache die ich auf der jvm halbwegs kann javascript css html eigentlich
ganz gut mittlerweile ich habe mal was in assembler gemacht nicht dass ich jetzt sagen würde
ich habe da großplan von c bin ich die bessere sprache als c++ aber c++ kann ich besser
wobei es an c prinzipiell ja nicht viel zu lernen gibt außer dass es halt sehr mühselig
ist und c++ halt die abgefuckteste sprache die es gibt aber c++ ist mittlerweile ganz
ganz brauchbar ja besch kann ich ziemlich gut shell script beste ruby kann ich auch
ziemlich gut dort netzey sharp kann ich auch ziemlich gut wie gesagt javascript so geht
mittlerweile auch recht gut habe ich was vergessen java habe ich keine ahnung von content habe
ich auch keine ahnung von dart dart haben wir letztens auch mal was gemacht da war ich
das habe ich jetzt nicht wirklich plan von python ist ganz ok ja kann ich kann ich lesen
kann ich schreiben ist jetzt nicht unbedingt meine absolut favorite sprache aber das geht
funktionales kann ich nix wirklich also rust noch das funktionalste hast du dir das selbst
beigebracht ja ja zum größten teil schon bleibt dir nix anderes übrig wirklich wirklich
technik kam lernen kann man eigentlich nur selbst du kannst das dann verbessern und vielleicht
fürs business umfeld anpassen aber wirklich lernen kannst du es eigentlich nur nur du
selbst ich meine du kannst vielleicht bei den ein oder anderen webcast gucken oder die
vielleicht auch irgendwie mal so ein wenn es ganz gut klasse irgendwie den advanced kurs
kaufen irgendwo oder anschauen das was anderes aber wirklich lernen muss das eh selbst geht
ja nicht anders so also bin ich ja nicht stehen geblieben was wollte ich euch erzählen genau
also ihr wisst ja dass ich home assistant verwende für meine heim automatisierung aber
ich habe jetzt mal in iow broker reingeguckt iow broker gefällt mir von der oberfläche
und allem ehrlich gesagt gar nicht aber iow broker hat paar ziemlich coole plugins habe
ich mir gedacht warum kann man nicht zumindest die basic sachen easy vom iow broker in home
assistant importieren von der idee her ist es einfach man kann einfach die ganzen sachen
aus dem iow broker per mqtt exportieren ein bisschen umwursten und als sensor in home
assistant importieren automatisch das sollte relativ einfach gehen es hat glaube ich schlicht
und ergreif noch keiner gemacht den umgedrehten weg gibt es von iow broker zu home assistant
dotly states abrufen das hat schon einer gemacht ja es gibt zum beispiel ganz cooles iow broker
plugin was ich gefunden habe was ich auch mal ausprobiert habe was wirklich nice ist
und wo ich keinen bock habe so was selbst zu basteln einfach weil es viel maintenance
aufwand ist der kerl hier zum beispiel von dem habe ich übrigens auch von dem habe ich
übrigens auch ein paar sachen für das fiat plugin für home assistant abgucken können
der hat nämlich auch einen iow broker plugin gebaut für fiat apis und der hat zum beispiel
ein paketetracker gebaut der amazon pakete tracken kann und dhl pakete tracken kann so
richtig nice es war natürlich direkt bei mir verbackt ich hatte irgendwo einen bug report
sogar aufgemacht ja how to log in amazon hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert bis ich dann
drauf gekommen bin ach das liegt daran weil das hardcoded auf deutsch ist und ich habe
mein amazon auf englisch stehen und das hat er aber instant gefixt also es heißt der kümmert
sich um seine plugins so und das ist was wo ich gerne in meinem home assistant verwenden
würde allerdings nicht verwenden kann weil es eben ein iow broker plugin ist deswegen
müssen wir mal den iow broker starten und dann gucken wir mal
my code now never sub never donated neighbors wifi free entertainment dafür dafür ist
es open source und dafür ist es mit license was meinst du übrigens auch es kann auch
jeder klauen moin kurze frage du wolltest mal ein türsensor wetterfest machen hat es
irgendwie geklappt macht mir sorgen wir müssen ja hat es geklappt also es gibt verschiedene
möglichkeiten ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher welcher das war was ich erzählt habe im stream
beziehungsweise was ich gezeigt habe also es gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten sensoren
und boards sage ich gleich was zu es gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten sensoren und boards
dir kannst eingesetzt werden eine Absage und abwarten bis zu larva lite abwarten bis
180 then rubber square rubber fisk und 4.90 etwas seit ich gar nicht mehr sieben
Wenn ihr das richtig zu macht, Plastiktüte ist nicht, wenn das einfach den ganzen Tag
über ein halbes Jahr draußen liegt, also Plastiktüte kann man vergessen.
Das nächste ist, und das passt allerdings nicht für ein Türsensor, ist irgendeine
Box, irgendeine IP54, besser IP65 Box, da ist das dicht und wenn man sich dann eine
Kabeldurchführung kauft, also zum Beispiel so eine Box hier, irgendeine wasserdichte
Box, kann man sich kaufen, gibt es auch kleine, so Dinge in der Richtung, ja, und die gibt
es dann auch mit Kabeldurchführungssachen und so, das ist wirklich dicht, da kann man
nichts sagen, das ist dicht, Problem ist für ein Türsensor geht es nicht, weil die
Box zu groß ist. So, die nächste Variante, die es gibt, es gibt so Lack oder so, so Isolationszeug
zum sprühen, da kann man auch manche Sensoren, zumindest wenn die prinzipiell wasserdicht
sind, allerdings Öffnungen haben, die nicht richtig wasserdicht sind, kann man die besprühen
damit und dann sind die auch ganz gut wasserdicht, damit kann man theoretisch sogar nackische
PCB Boards rauslegen, wenn man das damit besprüht, dafür kannst du halt nichts mehr
dranlöten danach, logisch, wenn das wasserdicht ist, kannst du auch nichts mehr einfach dranlöten,
das ist wahrscheinlich so eine Art Kunstharz, wie manche Hersteller das machen, das ist
dann auch dicht. So und was ich gemacht habe, um den Sensor wasserdicht zu machen Leute,
die einfachste Variante überhaupt, ich hab mir einen dicken Schrumpfschlauch genommen,
hab den Sensor reingesteckt und hab ihn zugeschrumpft, dann hab ich das vorne und hinten umgeschlagen,
bisschen länger war der Schlauch, dann hab ich das vorne und hinten umgeschlagen und
fertig. Und der Schrumpfschlauch hat den Vorteil, das legt er auch richtig eng an und nimmt
quasi kaum mehr Platz weg, wie der ursprüngliche Sensor. Ah Kondome ist ein bisschen schwierig,
kannst du auch machen, ist natürlich auch wasserdicht, Kondome hat eine ziemlich große
Öffnung, klar du kannst das auch verknoten oder so, das funktioniert, das ist dann auch
wasserdicht, aber das ist halt recht dünn und gerade so ein Türöffnensensor, je nachdem
wie der angebracht ist, da kann durchaus auch mal was dran reiben und da sagt ihr jetzt
ja dafür sind Kondome gut, ja aber die sind nicht gut, wenn Metall dran reibt, also Allotrix
Schniedl ist nicht gut, das funktioniert nicht, also wenn da Metall dran reibt, auf
Dauer gehts kaputt. Und gerade vom Hoftor, da wo ich das wasserdicht machen wollte, reibt
bisschen Metall dran und dementsprechend geht das nicht. Also ich würde einen dickeren,
nicht einen breiteren, vom Durchmesser her, Schrumpfschlauch empfehlen, der gerade so drüber
passt und dann ordentlich schrumpfen und dann ist das wirklich ordentlich, dann machst
du die Enden, kannst du umschlagen nach hinten und dann ist das dicht, kannst dann zusammentackern
oder so, Heißkleber reinfüllen oder zu schmelzen oder keine Ahnung. Was auch gut ist, ist Silikonband,
Silikonband ist auch ganz nice, für Sachen wasserdicht machen, Silikonband, weiß nicht
wie das heißt, ja sowas in der Richtung, das ist auch ganz nice um Sachen wasserdicht
zu machen, weil das klebt selbst, also das kannst du quasi aneinander kleben, das musst
du dann ordentlich langziehen, dass das ordentlich, dass das ein bisschen Spannung drauf hat und
schön eng anliegt, dann kannst du drumherum machen und dann klebt das selbst und ist auch
zu. Ja oder kannst du Silikon, alles mögliche. Aber Silikon ist ein bisschen blöd, da brauchst
es noch, da liegt es nicht mehr so eng an, also es gibt verschiedenste Möglichkeiten.
Die sind tatsächlich noch zum größten Teil aktuell, da tut sich nicht viel, das geht
einfach. Wieso IO-Blocker, weil es coole Plugins gibt für IO-Blocker, zum Beispiel hier dieses
Paket-Tracker-Plugin. Ja gab gestern kein Aufwachstream. Moin Shailor, auch am Start,
Pog. Ja zum größten Teil, also die Steuerungsbox ist fertig, da ist jetzt ein Shelly-Uni drinne,
ich hab doch mein selbstgebautes Zeug nicht verwendet, ich hab mir für 15 Euro ein Shelly-Uni
gekauft. Hat nämlich noch weitere Vorteile, also das Gute an dem, was genau passiert hier,
das Gute an dem ist nämlich, wenn man da jetzt vielleicht mal schöne Bilder von finden würde.
Ja das ist ja wieder richtig pepega. Ja so sieht er aus, ein Shelly-Uni. Kacke. Ja so
schönes Bild, das ist gut. Also so ein Teil hat den Vorteil, der funktioniert direkt mit
24 Volt, ohne größere Probleme, ohne extra Spannungswandler und sonst, also was heißt
ohne extra Spannungswandler, selbstverständlich hat er extra Spannungswandler, aber die sind
schon mit drauf. Guck mal, die haben hier auch so eine Art Kunstharz drüber, sowas
kann man auch selbst sich holen und draufsprayen. Das ist eine programmierbare Gabel, sieh
das mal ein bisschen so aus. Hat tatsächlich gewisse Ähnlichkeit. Zumindest, hier vorne
hast du zwei Relays eingebaut, also alles direkt 24 Volt fähig und hier hinten hast
du noch ein paar GPIO Pins, das heißt hiermit kann ich das Tor schalten, einmal nur G-Tür
drauf, einmal alles auf, brauchst ja zwei dafür und theoretisch könnte ich da hinten
über die GPIOs noch beispielsweise einen Sensor anschließen, der guckt, ob die Tür auf und
zu ist und sowas. Oder aber, dass irgendwie beispielsweise in der Steuerung noch an die
LEDs dran löten, um zu gucken, ob gerade Fehler angezeigt werden und sowas. Also so ein Teil
habe ich da jetzt drin, ist natürlich viel kompakter als das, was ich gebaut habe. Dementsprechend
eigentlich ganz nice. Das ist drin, das habe ich auch vor ein paar Tagen angeschlossen
ans Tor, um es mal auszuprobieren, funktioniert wunderbar. Ich brauche jetzt noch die Erlaubnis
von meinem Nachbar, an der einen Ecke ein bisschen was zu schrauben und dann kann ich
eigentlich hinstellen und dann auf und zu machen. Ja, so siehts aus.
Ich habe ein Haus mitten in der Stadt und bei mir kommen Leute ins Garten und kotzen
oder pissen rein. Ich will die irgendwie davon abhalten, mit Licht oder was weiß ich. Bist
du in München und wohnst du in der Nähe, wo das Oktoberfest ist? Das sollte ein Riesenproblem
sein. Habe ich jetzt schon öfters gelesen, dass dort die ganzen, dass auch teilweise
die Leute besoffen im Garten liegen und sowas dann. Also hm, was gibt es denn da? Ich meine,
Wassersprengler wäre auf jeden Fall eine nice Sache. Tut keinem weh. Licht, Licht, ja, wobei
ich nicht weiß, ob die, die freuen sich wahrscheinlich, wenn Licht an ist. Dann sehen sie wenigstens
noch, wo sie hin pinkeln. So ein Wassersprinkler, so ein Wassersprinkler, der angeht auf Bewegung,
na gut, da verjagt sie die Katze auch von eben dran. Sound abspielen, Sound abspielen
würde auch funktionieren, aber ich weiß nicht, ob die das interessiert. Tor über Tor aufmachen,
auf Pfeil fährt, ja. Ach du Scheiße, Mann, das ist ja hart. Ne, das brauchen wir nicht,
was ihr wollt. So, ich hoffe, ich habe alles beantwortet jetzt. Wir starten jetzt mal den
IO Broker. IO Broker, Docker, Official, Official Image. Erstmal kurz mal den Docker restarten,
weil der buggt immer rum, wenn ich die VM aus dem Standby hole. Hier, IO Broker, Docker
Image. Ja. Postchamp. Die Seite möge sich öffnen. Docker HUBDOWN, Kegwaid. Passt zu.
Ok, Docker HUBDOWN oder Vodafone DAWN. Wechselst du jetzt auf IO Broker? Nein, ich will aber
IO Broker Images verwenden. Sag mal, was ist denn hier los? Hub.Docker. Hub.Docker. Ist
Docker HUBDOWN oder was? Das muss Vodafone sein, was anderes fällt mir nicht ein. Äh.
Firefox, Keg. Ach ja, ach ja, Firefox, ach ja. Jetzt wo ich dich überführt habe, dass
es in Chrome geht, jetzt gehts auf einmal. Ist klar. Jetzt ist klar. Ja. Ok, wie startet
man den Kram? Die hatten doch hier sowas. Da. IO Broker, IO Broker. Ok, Temp. Ich glaube,
ok, was auch immer, mir gehen langsam die Namen aus. Es wird ja immer schlimmer. mkdir
IO Broker. Ok, zack. Docker Run Name IO Broker. H? Was ist denn H? Was ist denn minus H? Hostname?
Docker minus H? Ok, wir lassen uns das jetzt erklären. Besser als Manpage gucken. Docker
minus H. Explain. Wie, das kann der nicht? Alter. Keg. Systemtray von. Das ist kein Systemtray.
Das ist Minus H. Help. Nein. Host. Ich liebe ja diese tollen Hilfeseiten. Ich lasse das
einfach weg. Weiß nicht, was es macht. Ok, Docker Run 8081 Name IO Broker. Blablablablablablablabla.
Ok, auf geht's. Spooky Musik. Halloween ist bald, oder? Ich habe kaum Dance Gaming diesen
Monat geguckt. Dabei gucke ich den übertrieben gerne. Und gerade in seinem Horror Month gucke
ich den gerne. Aber irgendwie dieses Jahr. Ich glaube, ich habe nicht genug Zeit gehabt.
Ich gucke immer noch gerne. Und Dance Gaming ist seit Jahren der einzige Let's Player,
den ich gucken kann. Weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht. Guckt ihr überhaupt noch Let's
Plays? Meistens sind wahrscheinlich mittlerweile gerade deutsche Let's Plays, glaube ich, jetzt
weiß ich, wie angesagt das die letzten Jahre. Ich keine Ahnung. Weiß ich nicht. Go Behörde
Arbeiten. Ok, meinst du, ich sollte mich doch noch mal bei dir melden, deswegen ja. Easy
Live Behörden. Easy Behörden Live. Crank habe ich tatsächlich noch nie geguckt. Doomzap,
sehr schön für den Zapp. So, IO Broker scheint am Start zu sein. Nee, Crank habe ich noch
nie geguckt. Ich habe auch, also ich gucke prinzipiell eigentlich so gut wie keine Let's
Plays. Ich überlege gerade. Also, wie gesagt, ich gucke eigentlich auf Twitter, ich gucke,
der einzige Let's Player, den ich über Jahre schon gucke ist Dance Gaming. Früher habe
ich mal Sir Ron Lionheart geguckt, falls den jemand kennt. Den kennt keiner mehr. Der hat
vor 10 Jahren mal Videos gemacht, hat irgendwie nur 8000, 1000 Aufruf. Der hat Nintendo Spiele
gespielt und hatte irgendwie Roleplay dabei. Das war ganz abgedrehter Shit. Clown27, danke
schön für den Zapp. Du kennst den? Macht ja nichts mehr. Ansonsten habe ich nie, habe
ich nie Let's Plays geguckt. So, ist das jetzt gestartet alles? Ja, also, Local Horse 8081,
Boomerwitz, ich weiß. Da sind wir. IO Broker, Brokert. Welcome. Ich agreee. Agreege, machen
wir. Administratorname, Admin. Oh, das ist Hardcoded. Administrator Pass. Secure Passwort.
Das verkennt mich Firefox aber schlecht, Secure Passwort. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8. Moment. At least 8 Characters. Was soll denn das hier, wenn es fertig ist?
Cringe. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. Have numbers, upper and lower case letters. Ok, ich lasse
doch. Ich lasse doch Firefox generaten. Authentification für Admin meinetwegen. Nein, nein, nein, kein
Port Forwarding. Allow. Ja, allow mal. Alles klar, da wohnen wir, sehr gut.
Ok. Finish. Go to Admin. Was? Nein, nein, ich will nichts discoveren. Admin. Stay logged
in. Close. Ok. Moment, Moment. Darkseam. Ah, yes. Shot besser, oder? Startet schneller
als Home Assistant. Sieht nur so aus, glaube. So, also das ist ioproker und da gibt es jetzt
coole Plugins, wie zum Beispiel das da, um seine Pakete zu verfolgen. Das kann ich jetzt
hier im Stream nicht zeigen, weil dann müsste ich mich bei Amazon einloggen und dann würde
ich meine Adresse leaken und meine Koordinaten leaken und alles, das will ich nicht. Alter.
Das heißt, ich muss mir jetzt irgendwelche Fake Sensoren installieren, dass ich ein bisschen.
Ne, Corona hatte ich erst. Dass ich ein bisschen Daten hier in ioproker kriege. Also von der
Idee her machen wir folgendes. Ich installiere jetzt ein paar ioproker Plugins, so Wetter
ist zum Beispiel gut. Wetter. Und dann greifen wir das ganze per MQTT ab und schicken sein
Home Assistant. Muss mal kurz schauen, dass ich mal ein Home Assistant nicht updaten muss.
Fiat Champ hat ein Update. So sieht es aus. Fiat Champ direkt updaten. F. Über. Updates.
Aktualisieren, ein Backup erstellen. Ach was. Mach mal updaten. Der Fiat Champ ist sogar
3.0 theoretisch schon. Wenn er mit seinem Truck mal in die Pötte kommen würde. Okay,
das war's interessant. Ich brauch irgendwelche random. Api Key. Ne, ich will nichts mit Api
Key haben. Ohne Api Key. Wässer. Das Wetter.com. Braucht man dafür Api Keys? You need an
account. Mensch. Gibt es nicht Wetter ohne. Gibt es nicht. Deutscher Wetterdienst ohne
Api. Please, please ohne Api. Ach, Wetterwarnings. Das sind Wetterwarnings, okay. Ja, das können
wir machen. Luftdaten. Da können wir auch ein paar Sensoren einbilden. Meteo Alarm.
Ich brauch irgendwas ohne. Irgendwas was kein Api Key braucht. Api. Okay, probieren wir
das mal aus. Ich brauch irgendwelche Sensoren, die sinnlos was. Chain Law und weiter. Was
soll ich damit? Ach so, das ist eine Trackingnummer. Ne, das bringt uns ja nichts. Der liest ja
aus dem Amazon Account aus. So, fügen wir jetzt einfach mal random was hinzu. Wetter.
Hoffentlich brauchen wir kein Api Key. Close. Choose Germany. Region. Helgoland. Hochtaunus
Kreis. Kann man da nicht suchen drin? Das ist natürlich Dorf. Wo ist denn Frankfurt? Kreis
Main. Hier Main. Was weiß ich? The fuck? Okay, ist eigentlich egal. Irgendwas hier Kreis,
Holder, ist doch wurscht. Layout. No, was? Don't show icons. Ich weiß noch nicht mal,
was es macht, aber okay. Save. Jetzt können wir in die Logs gucken, ob er Daten zieht,
ob er Wetterzeug zieht. Die UI ist wirklich ziemlich zum, man muss sich dran gewöhnen.
What? Hab ich doch. So, Objects. Hat er es jetzt erkannt? Metero Alarm. Alarms. Okay,
eine Alarme. Dann. Dann paar Luft, paar Luftsensor Daten. Das geht auch immer. Luft, Luftsensor
Daten. Sensor Community. Ich brauch einfach nur ein paar Daten, dass ich was übertragen
kann. Restes muss jetzt keinen Sinn haben. Frankfurt. So. Oh ja, hier, guck mal. Da geht
richtig was ab. Hat es jetzt kopiert? Natürlich nicht. So. Instances close. Sensors. Sensorname.
My City. Selbstverständlich. Frankfurt. Eins. Sensor. Nächster Sensor. Wir machen
jetzt ein paar rein. Da, hier. Offenbach. Half die Abi-Stadt. Alles klar. Ich blicke
mal. Ja. Macht das was? Starting. Terminated. Hat es jetzt was drinstehen? Luftdaten. Null.
Sensor. Name. Frankfurt. Minus eins. Hier, da, guck mal. Nice. Okay, das sollte an Daten
reichen. Ich will ja nur irgendwas übertragen. Es muss ja gar nichts Dolles sein. Hier Luftdaten.
Wunderbar. Offenbach. Offenbacher Luftdaten. Sebaro, der ist auch wieder da. Nice. Da
ist er auch wieder. Sebaro, wenn der Chainlaw weiter mit dem Scheiß rumspammt, diesmal
darfst du ruhig mal sieben Tage bannen oder sowas. Das hat schon seinen Grund, dass der
überall gebannt ist. Ich glaube nur noch bei mir darf er schreiben. Er kann es einfach
nicht lassen mit diesem West. So, also jetzt haben wir hier genug Daten drin. Okay, also
dann fangen wir doch mal an. Was ist das? Ah, das ist Output von meinem IO-Proker. Das
brauchen wir nicht. Also, machen wir mal ein neues Repo. Mkdir, wie nennen wir das denn?
IO-Proker to Home Assistant. Aber ohne Champ heute hinten dran. New Console. Ach so, haben
wir jetzt neueste.NET Preview installiert..NET. Habe ich das denn irgendwie gecurlt
mal in letzter Zeit? Ah, da war es. Fuck. Ah, what the fuck. Das ist blöd, wo ist es
dann hin? Da. Sechs Monate, Dankeschön Mr. Moogame. Ja, wir haben das aktuellste installiert.
Dann machen wir das mal auf. Ich habe ein paar dicke Finger, aber das klappt nicht.
Sudo Attempts Wrong. Ja, ja. So, Open. Nicht den Fiat Champ, sondern IO-Proker to Home
Assistant. Ach, habe ich noch gar keinen angelegt? Jetzt. Trust. Trust us. Okay. Also, von der
Idee her habe ich mir das folgendermaßen vorgestellt. Aber Paint, Paint Action. Also,
hier ist, hier ist, also, hier ist der IO-Proker. Massive. Massive Paint Job. Hier ist, hier
ist Home Assistant. So, und hier dazwischen, hier dazwischen soll jetzt mein Programm.
So, und das, das habe ich mir gedacht, macht folgendes. Das, das bekommt ein MQTT Server
und der IO-Proker verbindet sich zu dem MQTT Server und liefert dort ein Export seiner
Sensoren ein. Dann nimmt er das entgegen, konvertiert das irgendwie in ein Format, was
Home Assistant versteht und dann pusht er das per MQTT weiter an Home Assistant. Das
hat den Vorteil, dass man so alle Sensoren aus IO-Proker theoretisch nach Home Assistant
relativ easy bekommen kann. Der Rückweg funktioniert übrigens nicht. Also, das ist nur quasi
Read Only. So, Run. Warum habe ich da noch das Kill hinten dran stehen? Das brauche ich
wahrscheinlich nicht. Nicht genug Tabs. So, also, auf geht's. Gut, wir brauchen jetzt
erstmal ein MQTT Server, zu dem sich der IO-Proker verbinden kann und damit der IO-Proker sich
verbinden kann, brauchen wir einen MQTT Adapter. Der ist besser als der. Ich glaube, ihr habt
das schon ausprobiert. So, was habe ich für eine IP? Ach, wir sind doch nicht unter Windows.
Also, wir wollen uns verbinden dahin auf Port 1883 mit dem User IO-Proker und Passwort 123456.
So, Test Connect. Warum? Die Connection sollte nicht funktionieren?
Ich habe da auch kein... Ich habe da auch nichts drauf laufen. Passwort
ist falsch. Nö. Nicht falsch. Okay, keine Ahnung, was er für Schmerzen hat, aber soll
mir recht sein. Wir müssen erstmal den MQTT Server starten hier drauf. Also, brauchen
wir dafür MQTTnet, weil das der einzige ist, der mir einfällt, dass er sich verbinden
kann. So, und jetzt müssen wir mal auf GitHub gucken, wie man den Krempel verwendet. Samples,
weil Server verwende ich so gut wie nie. Client habe ich schon öfters verwendet, aber den
haben wir davon? Keine Ahnung. Also, Samples Server. Simple Samples. Simple Sample ist erst
mal 219 Zeilen lang, das macht mich zuversichtlich. Also, was macht der Typ da? MQTT Server. Start
MQTT Server. What? Create MQTT Server. Okay, okay, das klingt ganz sinnvoll. Das machen
wir jetzt. By the way, warum ist denn das da? Warum habe ich denn das hier noch mal auf?
Plötzlich. Das soll auf 3 und das soll auch auf 3. Plötzlich nicht. Prime, Dankeschön
für den Sub. Also. So, also wie funktioniert denn der Kram jetzt? MQTT Factory Create New
Server. Also, probieren wir das doch mal aus. MQTT Server gleich New MQTT Factory. Das muss
mehr Java aussehen, da brauchen wir noch einen Factory Manager Singleton Pattern, dass das
funktioniert. So, withDefault Endpoint. Wunderbar. Build. So, da brauchen wir die Zeile oben gar
nicht. Bisschen Zeilen sparen. So, MQTT Server. Zack. Und wie geht es jetzt weiter? MQTT Server
Start Async. Dann machen wir das mal. Dann sagen wir Console Readline und gucken wir,
ob das jetzt gestartet ist. Ob das schon reicht hier. Run. Und jetzt sagen wir NetStat und
gucken, ob der Port offen ist. 1883. Ja, sieht gut aus. Gucken wir mal, ob wir da uns connecten
können zu. Publish. Minus Host, glaube ich. Local Host. Wie funktioniert das? Wie? Minus
Minus Topic. Null. Minus Message. Ah ja. Connection Refused. Identifier Rejected. Alles klar.
Was auch immer uns ist. Zumindest kann er sich verbinden. Er kann sich verbinden, darf
sich aber nicht verbinden. Das ist doch schon mal ganz gut. Lass uns mal das Beispiel weiter
angucken. Was wir heute machen, das da. Wir bauen was, was den Sensoren Export von My
Own Broker entgegennimmt und umwandelt so, dass Homo System das versteht. Ja, eigentlich
schon. Das kann sein, dass das aktualisiert hat und du musst mal wieder das anmachen.
Du kannst in den Settings auch 7 TV Emotes anmachen. Allerdings habe ich kein 7 TV aktiviert,
das heißt bei mir müsstest du es auch so sehen. Ok, was hat er denn jetzt für Schmerzen
mit einem Identifier, der Rejected wird? Aha. MQTT Server Validating Connection Essring.
Alles klar. Machen wir. Machen wir. So, kriege ich da jetzt was angezeigt? Heck. Kriege
ich da jetzt was angezeigt, weil ich versuche zu verbinden? Hey. Nice, also das funktioniert
schon mal. Valid Client ID brauche ich, dass es funktioniert. Ok, ich glaube, das ist Minus
E und es muss Valid Client ID sein. User Name Password. Ok, jetzt gibt es einen anderen
Fehler. Also User. Valid User. Ok und groß P ist es glaube Secret Password. Hey, Kunst.
Nice. Wir können Messages Publishen auf unseren eigenen MQTT Broker. Fock. So, das lassen
wir jetzt erstmal so. Nee, Leute. Jetzt. Jetzt. Ups. Fack. Ich bin über das Kabel gefahren.
Jetzt bin ich fast vom Headset gezogen. Das Headset fast vom Kopf gezogen. Wir machen
jetzt mal was. Wisst ihr was? Jetzt machen wir High IQ Pattern Matching. Ob das schöner
zu lesen ist? Ja, fraglich, fraglich, aber High IQ Pattern Matching. Ja, wir können
es auch E nennen, ist auch ok. Mal gucken, ob ich das nämlich aus dem Kopf hinkriege.
Also, wir wollen letztendlich den Response Code setzen. So, lasst mal überlegen. Pattern
Matching. Also, wollen wir noch sowas haben wie E, Switch, den Default Case, Bent. Ok,
das ist schon mal von der Syntax her richtig, was ich da gemacht habe. So, das heißt jetzt
das als Switch. Also, wir wollen den User überprüfen, das heißt ich kann sowas machen.
Username. So, Username IO Broker ist erlaubt. Ansonsten nix. Jetzt wurden die Emotes angezeigt.
Nice. Pog. Ich finde, ich hab mich gerade dreimal beim Emote verklickt. Hier, das
wollte ich eigentlich. Lass das Copilot machen, dazu muss ich Copilot erst mal einschalten.
Also, wenn, ne, ok, ok, ne, Moment, Moment. Wir wollen die Sachen abfangen, die nicht
gültig sind. Also, unser Default Fall ist Success. Eigentlich, oder? Big Brain Features,
ja. Jetzt fängt es aber schon an. Wie sage ich denn? Not IO Broker. Also, ich will im
Prinzip sowas machen. Reason. Und dann irgendwie Client. Client. Not Valid. Die Sache ist die,
ich will Not IO Broker haben. Not. Aha. Das funktioniert. Username Not IO Broker. Dann
darf er nicht. Ok, next. Wenn Username Not IO Broker ist. Ne, nicht Username. Client.
Client ID. Not IO Broker ist. Username Not IO Broker. Ok. Und als nächstes, if Password
Not. 123456. Alles klar. Dann, ok. Kann man das noch einfacher machen? Zumindest, Leute,
ist das jetzt besser lesbar? Ihr entscheidet. Sagt mal, was findet ihr besser lesbar? Das
if oder das, also das macht das Gleiche hier. Wobei, ne, es macht nicht das Gleiche, stimmt
gar nicht. Das hier macht das Gleiche. So. Was findet ihr schöner? Das da? Oder das
da? In C++ würde es besser aussehen, mit Sicherheit. Weil es die C++ bekannt dafür
ist, dass in C++ alles besser aussieht. Vor allem die, die, die Datetime-Chrono-AP sieht
viel besser aus, gell? Das zweite, ja, ich finde auch tatsächlich, dass es gar nicht
so verkehrt ist. So. Chrono ist vom feinsten Jahr. Datetime-Delta-Offset-Convert-from-Dings-to-millisecond.
Das ist so abartiger Krabbel. So. Also. Jetzt, jetzt können wir uns zumindest schon mal anmelden
mit den, mit den richtigen, mit den richtigen Daten. Nämlich. Run. Nämlich, wenn ich mich
jetzt hier anmelde als User IOProker, Secret Password 123456 und als Client IOProker, dann
Funst. Okay. So. Wie lese ich denn jetzt Nachrichten, die published werden in meinem MQTT-Server?
Message. Ich bilde mir ein, es gab mal sowas wie Received, Application Message Received
oder sowas. Gibt es das nicht mehr? Ist das zu, zu modern mittlerweile, oder? Man muss
bestimmt einen Client nehmen. Warum? Ich will, ich will noch mitbekommen, welche, wenn eine
Message published wird auf den Server. Das muss doch eine Server-Sache sein. Wir haben
doch mal ein Wiki mit Beispielen, oder? Ja. Server. Server. Reparation, ja, meinetwegen.
Intercepting Application Messages. Was? Application Message Interceptor? What the hell? Was?
Nee, gibt's überhaupt nicht mehr. Gibt's überhaupt nicht mehr. Nice. She baited. Was
macht der IOProker? Im Prinzip ein bisschen das, was Home Assistant macht, nur Konkurrenzprodukt,
aber es gibt ein paar ganz coole Plugins dafür. MQTTnet Server Received. Ja.
Was? Connection Validator. Consuming Messages, genau. Server is able to process Application
Message Received. Ja, das gibt's aber nicht. She baited. Okay. Wir durchsuchen die GitHub
App. Show me sample code. Hä? Okay, issues. Upgrades. Okay, okay, da hat sich wahrscheinlich
was getan. MQTT Message Received Callback does not exist anymore. Nee, Inject Application
Message kann's ja nicht sein. Intercepting Publish. Meine Fresse, da kommt doch nie jemand
drauf. Intercepting Publish. Also jetzt immer im Ernst. Wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen,
wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen MQTT Server, Application Message Received Event oder MQTT
Server Intercepting Publish Async. Was ist das erste, wonach ich gucken werde? Doch
nach da und nicht danach. Intercepting Publish Async. Upgrading Guide. Ah, okay, da steht
vielleicht was drinne. Tatsächlich, das ist, das ist der offizielle way, the way, das jetzt
zu machen, the way. Die denken sich da immer Zeug aus, also man kann's auch verkomplizieren.
Saved. Also. Intercept, Intercepting, das kann ich ja mal aussprechen. Intercepting Publish
Async. Okay, also. Application Message Topic. Dann schauen wir doch mal, ob da irgendwas
reinkommt, wenn ich das jetzt ausführe. Ich einfach entwickle am Werk, aber echt. Hey,
Lul, da ist es. Topic Lul. Sehr schön. Nice. So, das heißt wir bekommen Messages. Jetzt
können wir eigentlich schon checken, ob der IO Broker sich verbinden kann. IO Broker,
wo ist er? Da. Save. So, was haben wir da sonst noch zu bieten? MQTT Setting, Subscribe Patterns.
Wollen wir überhaupt Subscriben? Ich darf, ich darf nur noch Closen. Sonst nix. So,
ich jetzt, darf ich jetzt die Verbindung mal testen, ob die funktioniert? Oops. Connection
Test. Ja, Moment, wenn ich Connection Test mache, muss ich hier oben irgendwas reinschreiben.
Ob das ich versuche zu verbinden. Was ist das für ein Crap? Warum kann ich das, muss
ich das immer zumachen? Test Connection. Nee, tut sich nix. Okay, wie auch immer. Ist
das überhaupt meine IP? Ist das Ding überhaupt richtig? Ja, ist richtig. Okay, MQTT Setting,
Subscribe Patterns. Alter, die Bedienung. Ich muss beim Docker Run den MQTT Port mit
aufmachen. Nee, nee, nee, nee, muss ich nicht. Die Verbindung geht doch umgedreht aus dem
Docker Contrainer raus. Muss man das rote Play Symbol drücken? Ja, aber erst nachdem
ich es konfiguriert habe, ich versuche die ganze Zeit was zu konfigurieren. Publish only
on changes. Nein, wollen wir nicht. State Objects wollen wir. Leute, glaubt's mir, ich weiß
nicht wirklich was ich mache, aber ich weiß insofern das, was ich mache, weil ich im Vorfeld
dieses Plugin schon mal ausprobiert habe. So, wir haben jede Menge lange Messages. Okay.
Glaubt das stimmt soweit. Hier muss man jetzt gleich noch angeben, was er exportieren soll
und hier, das habe ich auf GitHub gelesen, hier muss man jetzt noch angeben. Irgendwo
kann man doch jetzt einen Prefix angeben, oder? Prefix for all topics. Einmal IO Broker davor.
Hier kann man angeben, was er exportieren soll und das hier ist ganz wichtig, das habe
ich vorhin auf GitHub gefunden. Hier muss man irgendwas reinschreiben, zum Beispiel
tackle unused, weil ansonsten, haltet euch fest, ansonsten subscribt er zu sich selbst
und landet in eine Endlosschleife, weil er auf dem gleichen Broker subscribt und seine
Werte bekommt und dann subscribt er sich selbst und dann geht er kaputt. Das habe ich vorhin
auf GitHub gelesen. So, okay, save and close. Auf geht's. MQTT starten please. Aha, er hat
sich verbunden, okay, nice. Was? Identifier rejected? Ach, habe ich nicht angegeben, dass
es der Name IO Broker sein soll. Client ID, aha IO Broker, alles klar, save. Ah, hey,
er hat was published, IO Broker Info Connection hat er published. Okay, der verbindet sich,
das ist nice. Jetzt können wir auch mal gucken, wir müssen was vom Fiat Champ kopieren, Sekunde.
Wichtig. Der Fiat Champ wird jetzt ausgeschlachtet. Fiat Client Helper. Beste Sache, die ich gebroggert
habe die letzten paar Jahre über. Äußerst praktisch, gibt es wahrscheinlich schon als
fertige Library, aber das finde ich immer, das brauche ich jetzt jedes Projekt. Pass
mal auf, Massify IQ. Extension Method. Oh, wir brauchen Jason.net. Einfach mehr Dependencies
please. Guck mal, Guck mal, Six Hand, wisst ihr was man jetzt machen kann? Da hast du
recht Sirius Max, das ist richtig. Guck mal, ich kann jetzt einfach sagen, Application
Message Punkt Dump und jetzt, und jetzt, pass mal auf, ich hoffe der reconnectet sich automatisch.
Reconnectet er sich automatisch, ich hoffe. Please reconnecten. Reconnecten. Zack, guck
mal, und schon dumpt er den Inhalt. Das ist total simpel. Ich Jason serialise das einfach.
Einmal Jason serialise und einmal deserialise. Nee, schwachsinnig deserialise. Einfach das
Objekt serialise als Extension Method. Ich weiß, man könnte das sicherlich auch mit
dem eingebauten Jason Serialiser machen, aber das ist nice. Guck mal, so funktioniert das.
Bisschen Magic ist dabei, und zwar, also ist der Extension Method auf Object, heißt im
Endeffekt, man kann sogar Null übergeben. Das heißt, überall funktioniert das. So,
und jetzt kommt Trick 17. Ich muss sagen, das habe ich von Stag Overflow, ansonsten
wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen, weil man möchte ja auch manchmal das Ergebnis von was ausgeben,
was Async ist und auf das man awaiten muss. Das heißt, normalerweise müsste man dann
sagen, war, blub, gleich, await, Null, und dann kann man quasi erst das hier dann dumpen,
so. Aber ich will ja das hier direkt dumpen. Und da gibt es Trick 17, das habe ich auf
Stag Overflow gefunden. Guck mal, das hier. Ich kann nicht so genau erklären, was es macht,
aber es ist Massify IQ und es funktioniert. Ja, also zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, ich zeige
euch mal was. Also zum Beispiel, HTTP Client, new HTTP, HTTP Client, so und jetzt HTTP Client,
get Async, HTTP Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt, Google.de, ok? So, get, ne, so, fertig. Normalerweise,
was müsste ich machen, wenn ich das Ergebnis ausgeben will von HTTP Client? So, da müsste
ich mal result und dann könnte ich das ausgeben, await, await result, das müsste ich machen.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen doof. So, was ich jetzt machen kann, ist folgendes. Man
könnte übrigens auch noch einstellen, dass der direkt ausgibt. Jetzt kann ich sagen,
das hier, das ist jetzt in dem Fall ein doofes Beispiel, ja, gebe ich zu, weil es einen String
direkt zurück gibt. Ich will ja ein Objekt ausgeben. Und jetzt awaited durch dieses Ding
hier, guckt er nämlich, ob Object ein Task ist. Wenn Object ein Task ist, dann awaitet
er auf den Task und dann holt er sich das Result aus diesem Task raus und das nimmt
er dann, um es zu serialise und um es zu serialise. Das heißt, ich kann das mit Async Objects
verwenden und nicht, also mit Tasks und nicht Async Sachen. Ich meine, bei dem String ist
relativ doof, den zu dampen, das interessiert mich ja nicht, aber bei sowas hier, sprich,
wenn das hier Async wäre, könnte ich das einfach mal, man könnte übrigens in den
Tat noch sowas einbauen, wie Print gleich True oder irgendwie sowas, wenn man will.
Oder falls man das ausgeben möchte, ja, kann man sich überlegen, dass man das direkt,
dass man das theoretisch direkt ausgeben kann. Aktuell krept es als String zurück. Oder
man würde, man würde es Debug oder so nennen und dann mit einem Print unten drunter. Warum
eigentlich nicht? Moment, Moment, Sixhead Time. Irgendwie so. Muss ich das jetzt eigentlich
erwarten? Nee, muss ich nicht erwarten. Wieso? Ja, das müsste auch funktionieren. Und jetzt
kann ich direkt eigentlich e.ApplicationMessage so machen. Und jetzt soll das gleich ausgeben.
Es gibt ein Debug Attribut. Ja, das kann man machen. Das ist sogar relativ clever zu
verwenden. Der kompiliert das dann sogar nur, wenn es im Debug Mode ist. Und wirft die
andere raus. Du nützt die Methode in 25 nicht, was? Doch. Ach so. Lul, hast recht. Ja. So
und jetzt sollte er das eigentlich printen, ohne dass ich irgendwie sich konsult. Guck
ja, zack, ohne ich sich konsult. Wobei ich sagen muss, Leute, in letzter Zeit, ich hab,
ich hab gefallen an Dings hier gefunden. Ich hab immer bisher das eingebaute Loggingzeug
verwendet. Auch diese ganzen I-Logger Geschichten von ASP.Nightcore. Ich hab in letzter Zeit
gefallen gefunden an Serilog. Finde ich sehr praktisch. Besser als reines Command Line
loggen. Logger sind overrated. Ja, hast recht. Wir müssen einfach fehlerfrei programmieren.
Kann nix loggen. Easy. Ja, habt ja recht, ist ja so. Debug. Ja, weil da könnte ich jetzt
zum Beispiel sowas hier machen. Ich sag's heute zum ersten Mal in einem Tesla. Nice.
Da könnte ich jetzt zum Beispiel sowas machen wie Log Information. Und dann könnten wir
hier beispielsweise e.loggen. Oh, Message Template, das war was anderes. Da müsste ich
jetzt so machen. Und dann sieht das sogar, wenn man das jetzt loggt, ganz schick aus,
weil dann automatisch, wenn ich das richtig mache, what the fuck. Äh, warum ist denn da
so ne, das hat überhaupt nix zu suchen. Meine Güte, ey. Kann ich's mal richtig tippen.
So. Locked Critical Information, ja. Und jetzt sieht das nämlich folgendermaßen aus, wenn
man loggt. Nee, nee, Debug Dump ist, das ist verkehrt, so ist richtig. Postchamp. Zack,
guck. Und jetzt kriegt man das geloggt, sogar mit, mit was es für ein Log Level ist und
hat da Zeit automatisch dabei. Ist das nicht nice. Aber so advancede Sachen müssen wir
jetzt gar nicht schon machen. So. Also. Das Ding schickt uns jetzt regelmäßig irgendwelche
Daten über MQTT. Wir müssen jetzt erstmal schauen, was wir denn uns per MQTT schicken
lassen wollen. Wir wollen nämlich gar nicht diesen Standard Kram haben, sondern wir wollen
unsere, das stimmt wohl Spooky Coder, da hast du recht, die Luftdaten wollen wir schicken.
So, mal Luftdaten. Dazu wollen wir jetzt, wie heißt der Kram, Luftdaten, Luft, Luftdaten
Punkt Sternchen wollen wir exportieren. Dann schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ups. Der soll, guck, zack. Luftdaten exportiert, easy. Also das funktioniert schon mal. Jetzt
müssen wir die Sachen natürlich noch in Home Assistant kriegen. Was will der eigentlich
von mir hier? Ganz schön. Also wir bekommen den Krampel jetzt rein. Das ist doch schon
mal nice. Das funktioniert alles. So, also export for my outbroker funktioniert. Wie
kriegen wir diesen Krampel jetzt in Home Assistant rein? Das machen wir erstmal alles weg da
oben. Das braucht keiner. So, wenn wir, lasst mal kurz überlegen. Wie machen wir das jetzt
am besten? Ich glaube, ich muss mir noch was vom Fiat Champ klauen. So, also wir bekommen
jetzt die Messages rein mit den Informationen aus dem my outbroker. Okay, also machen wir
so was hier. Message, Application Message, also bisschen kürzer wird. Und jetzt müssen
wir alle im Topic alle Slashes durch Underscores ersetzen. Warum? Weil Home Assistant keinen
Slash erlaubt im Sensornamen, bzw. in der Entity ID heißt das in Home Assistant. Also wir
translaten jetzt alle Slashes zu Underscores. Also Message, Payload to String, Replace,
Slash. Das hat bestimmt irgendwelche Edge Cases, wo es nicht funktioniert, wie ich mir
das vorstelle. So, das ist die ID für den Sensor. So, das könnten wir jetzt tatsächlich
mal loggen, dass man, dass man weiß, was was Sache ist. Information und zwar. Wir loggen
jetzt Message, Payload und die ID. Ich will übrigens nicht den Payload, sondern das Topic
replacen. So. Und das ist das, was wir zu Home Assistant exportieren müssen. Ist MQTT
sparender oder warum fände man das statt einem normalen Push? Ja gut, es gibt keinen
normalen Push. Du könntest bei HTTP, kannst du, oh, guck mal hier, kommt der ganze Krämpel.
Du könntest HTTP pushen, das muss den Home Assistant aber explizit einschalten. Und das
Schöne ist, über MQTT kannst du den Home Assistant direkt Sensoren anlegen lassen mit
den passenden Attributen. Die sehen danach aus wie richtige Sensoren. Das sind nicht
einfach nur Textwerte, die du reinschreibst, sondern Home Assistant trackt das intern wirklich
als Sensor. Das nennt sich dann MQTT Autodiscovery oder irgendwie sowas bei Home Assistant. Guck
mal, Funst. Value Frankfurt Adapter. So, diesen ganzen Mist soll der jetzt mal, bitteschön,
nach Home Assistant exportieren. Vielleicht machen wir das übrigens umgedreht. Guck
mal das so, die ID zuerst und den Payload hinten dran. Okay, also, jetzt muss der Krämpel
irgendwie nach Home Assistant rein. Dazu brauche ich einen Client, der sich zu Home Assistant
verbindet, zum MQTT Server von Home Assistant verbindet. Das heißt, ich brauche jetzt noch
einen MQTT Client. Also, war MQTT Client? Lass mich raten, New MQTT Factory. Was sonst?
Ich meine, ich könnte es auch aus der gleichen Factory holen. Komm, ich hole es mal. Komm,
wir sind super sparsam. Nicht, dass es nur irgendeinen Unterschied macht. So, MQTT Server,
MQTT Client, Create Client. So, und jetzt muss ich abgucken, weil ich keinen Plastenschirm
einmal habe, wie das jetzt richtig funktioniert hat. New, nope, keine Ahnung. Wird vermutlich
eh zusammen optimal, ist das glaube ich nicht. So, MQTT Client, da können wir abgucken,
bei denen verwende ich hier schon. Wo ist der 4er Champ? Okay, im 4er Champ habe ich
eine eigene Klasse, die das macht. Die könnte ich mir jetzt eigentlich hier einfach rüber
kopieren und gut ist. Ist ja auch nicht so lang, aber ne, komm. MQTT Client Options,
MQTT Client ID Session. Neue Extension Method, Get MQTT Client Server Factory. Du meinst,
gibt es oder soll ich machen? Man könnte, wir brauchen noch ein Interface als IMQTT
Client Manager oder sowas. So, also so funktioniert das, okay. MQTT Client Options. Client ID,
wie heißt das Ding? IO Broker to Home Assistant Server 122168 2.132 war es glaube ich. Chat
hat irgendjemand aufgepasst? Hat irgendjemand aufgepasst, was mein Home Assistant für
eine IP hat? Ja, ist richtig. Exzellent. So, und da muss man noch irgendwas mit Autoconnect
machen, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Weil, weil halt, ne. MQTT Client und
wie geht es jetzt weiter? MQTT Client. Moment. Wo lege ich den denn an? Hier. Create Managed
MQTT Client. Oh nein. Create Managed MQTT Client ist es. Und dann muss ich sagen connect
oder sowas. Start Async. Start Async. Und jetzt wahrscheinlich Options, oder? Ja meine
Güte. Das ist auch durch die Brust ins Auge das Ding. Welches NuGet Paket benutzt du für
Command Line Programme? Das hier. Das hier. Hat mir bisher am besten gefallen. Es gibt
ja Hunderte davon mittlerweile. Sogar ein offizielles von Microsoft. Das hier. Das finde
ich ganz, ganz nett. Wie er das gemacht hat. Macht automatische Help Generation. Serialisiert
dein Parameter Zeug. Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Das verwende ich. Hab ich ja schon
für ein paar Sachen verwendet. Nicht Kekona. Passt. Passt Kekona. Es ist Kekona. Also
ja es ist schwierig das anders auszusprechen. Ist es nicht Kekona? Es ist Kokona. Ist von
irgendeinem Koreaner glaube ich. Kein China Kinese. Ein Koreaner hat das programmiert.
So jetzt haben wir unseren MQTT Client. Ok. So. Sixhead Time. Intercept Publish Async.
So ich hab den Campbell jetzt umgewandelt. Und ich muss daraus jetzt ein Format machen
was Home Assistant versteht. Ich mein ich könnte mir es einfach machen und den Kram
aus dem 4er Champ kopieren, weil dann mach ich genau das gleiche. Zumindest mal abgucken
können wir ja hier. Home Assistant. Device. HAA Device. Wo hab ich denn das? Ah da unten.
Das da. So. Das ist schon mal ganz praktisch. Das brauchen wir gleich. Und hier stehen die
ganzen Formate drin wie man das braucht. Ok. HAA Sensor. Ach komm. Ach komm. Wir copy
pasten das einfach rein und gut ist. Easy. So. Ja. Einfach rein pasten. Scheiß drauf.
Client. Publish. Nein. NQ Async. Alles klar. In das Config Topic. Was ist nochmal das Config
Topic? Ich sollte, ich sollte mal. Ah hier. Ok. Ah Home Assistant Sensor. ID. State Topic.
So Topic. Die Scharpe ist doch ganz hübsch. Ich mein das hier nicht, aber. State Topic.
ID. So ID ist das da. Oder? Wie baue ich die ID zusammen? Ich blick meine eigenen Kram
nicht mehr. Wo baue ich denn die? Wo baue ich denn die ID zusammen? Ah ID ist Device
Identifier und Name. Naja gut. Das ist tatsächlich relativ easy zu machen dann. Also. Das ist
die ID. Wie das Ding heißt in. Es passt eigentlich. Ich brauch eigentlich nur die ID hier. Fertig.
Das ist Unic. Das reicht. Moin Max du Tant. Bester Name. So Config Topic. Also. Hier
kommt die ID rein. Hier kommt die ID rein. So Device Model gibt es nicht. Manufacturer
gibt es auch nicht. Version gibt es auch nicht. Name. Ok Name ist tatsächlich. Ah Moment
das ist die Device ID. Die Device ID ist was anderes. Die Device ID ist. Was ist die Device
ID? Tja sowas hier würde ich sagen. IO Broker to Home Assistant. Kann ruhig Hardcoded sein.
Ist ok. So. Unit of Measurement haben wir nicht. Icon haben wir auch nicht. State Topic
haben wir. State Topic ist das. So und wenn ich das jetzt exportiere dann sollte in meinem
Home Assistant gleich was auftauchen. Hoffe ich mal. Habe ich mein MQTT Client gestartet?
Ja habe ich. Ach du Scheiße. Ok. Naja bin ja mal gespannt ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ok ok ok. Ok ok ok. War das nicht in World of Warcraft? War das nicht wenn du von Allianz
zu Horde Chat geschrieben hast ok ok ok war lol lol lol oder umgedreht? Ach nee keck was
keck nicht nicht ok ach was weiß ich weiß ich nicht mehr. So jetzt muss ich mal schauen
ob in meinem Home Assistant was aufgetaucht ist. Integrations. Geräte. Fuck. Natürlich
nicht. Das wäre jetzt auch zu einfach gewesen. Das heißt ich habe irgendwas falsch gemacht.
GitHub Copilot ich habe es ehrlich gesagt noch nie ausprobiert und jetzt wo es was
kostet kann ich noch nicht mehr ausprobieren. Leute das ist kacke dass es nicht funktioniert
was habe ich verkehrt gemacht? Was habe ich denn verkehrt gemacht? Warum hat das nichts?
Ich sollte jetzt hier eigentlich ein IO Broker, IO Broker to Home Assistants haben. Hätte
eigentlich funktionieren müssen. Das heißt ich habe mich vercopy pasted. Ok guck mal
in die Logs ob da irgendwas drin steht. Nee das ist natürlich doof. Da muss ich doch
mal in eigenem Kram copy pasten. Ja was mache ich denn falsch? Nix oder? MQTT ist der überhaupt
verbundene MQTT Client? MQTT Client start. Ok guck mal mal. MQTT Client is connected.
Schauen wir mal. Falls! Das ist schlecht. Warum nicht? Ah das kann nicht funktionieren.
Wie muss man sich da anmelden? Muss man eigenen Kram abgucken. Credentials. Ok MQTT ist es
glaube ich. Ich hoffe mal das das stimmt. Deswegen habe ich auch Leute. Deswegen habe
ich bei mir. Ich habe ja normalerweise hier diese MQTT Client Klasse gebaut die das für
mich macht. Deswegen habe ich hier unten dran das Connection Successful und Connection
nicht Successful. Nee das wird es natürlich erklären. Schauen wir mal. Connection Successful
ok nice. Jetzt sollte es funktionieren denke ich. Immer noch nicht. Fuck man warum nicht?
Wo ist denn das Problem schon wieder? Jetzt ist es aber wenigstens connected. Ok jetzt
soll man die Logs gucken. Oh unable to pass jason. Warum? Unable to pass jason. Warum?
Was ist hier falsch? Ist das nicht valid jason? Gucken wir mal. Hauen wir mal in
den parser rein. Punkt fr. Oh nee. End of data after property value. Habe ich irgendwo
ein Komma vergessen oder so? Darf ich? Ah guck dir mal. Da fehlt die Klammer zu. Kann
das sein? Muss das so sein? Und das Komma von der Klammer muss das so sein? Ok nochmal.
Connection Successful. Bam. 55. Hat es jetzt funktioniert? Integrations. Ah da ist es.
Komma zack. Luftdaten Sensor. Nice. Ok jetzt müssen wir noch das value exportieren. Das
ist relativ easy. Dazu. Dazu brauche ich das ganze Ding hier nicht. Dazu geht man einfach
an das state topic. Und schickt jetzt als payload einfach den Wert mit den man haben
will. Testen wir mal hier. Keck. Auf gehts. So jetzt sollte hier gleich überall keck drin
stehen. Mein chrome warum sollte der abschmieren? Das hat auch nicht viele tabs. Der andere
ja der andere. Komma. Keckl. Zack. Hat funktioniert. Nice. So IO Broker. Schonmal exportiert. Weil
das ist natürlich nicht den Wert den ich wirklich exportieren möchte. Ryder hat noch so ein
bisschen Probleme mit dem Syntax Highlighting oder? Ich glaube so. So checkt es das glaube
ich besser. Vielleicht so machen. Gucken wie man so multiline Dinger am besten formatiert.
Komma das blickt überhaupt nicht mehr durch. Ryder hat zumindest schon mal keine Fehler
mehr. Vorher hat es Fehler angezeigt. Aber zumindest kannst du es jetzt soweit dass es
keine Fehler mehr schmeißt. Ok also jetzt müssen wir noch den value exportieren. Was
wollen wir denn als value überhaupt haben? Komma wir bekommen hier value. True. Act.
True. TS. Eigentlich wollen wir davon doch nur. Ja eigentlich wollen wir davon doch
nur das value haben. Sonst nix. Heißt im Endeffekt wir wollen jetzt config topic. Nee Quatsch
nicht. Message. Was wollen wir denn haben? Wahr value gleich message. Payload. To string.
Und das wollen wir jetzt als json passen. J object pass. Das da. Und davon wollen wir
jetzt value haben. Ok mind thing to string. Gut. Und das schicken wir hier an den Home
Assistant. Und das müsste eigentlich schon gewesen sein. Vielleicht noch ein try catch
drum falls er mal Mist bekommt. Schauen wir mal das müsste eigentlich schon gewesen sein.
Easy. Schon aber er hat auch Brokerwerte importiert. Nice. Eats. Eats. Das ist tatsächlich
gar nicht so kompliziert gewesen. Das ist tatsächlich jetzt recht einfach. Aber mal
schauen ob da auch wirklich alles tut wie ich mir das vorstelle. So also das funktioniert
jetzt Nummer auf Nummer sicher zu gehen. Ich würde gerne ein bisschen mehr exportieren
und immer ein bisschen mehr exportieren um zu gucken ob ich nicht irgendwelche multithreading
Probleme habe oder so. Obwohl ich mache ja kein multithreading. Ich sollte mal multithreading
machen Leute. Das ist viel zu langsam was ich hier mache. Das ist nicht blazingly fast
written in rust Leute. Das geht nicht. Weil ich werde mit euch verbackt wenn ich das hier
lösche. Passt mal auf ich glaube es ist verbackt und ich weiß auch warum. Ist ja keine gute
Idee was ich hier gemacht habe. Also pass mal auf. Das ist jetzt verbackt. Ich zeig
es euch. Ich zeig es euch. Guck da. Zack verbackt. Seht ihr? Verbackt. Unbekannt. Unbekannt.
Warum? Weil ich Home Assistant sage neuen Sensor anlegen und ich direkt hinten drauf
den Wert für den Sensor pushe. Das heißt der Wert für den Sensor kommt bei Home Assistant
an bevor Home Assistant selbst den Sensor verarbeitet hat. Dann sieht das so aus. Das
heißt theoretisch müsste ich dazwischen. Mir fällt wirklich nichts anderes ein wie
den Task Delay zu machen. Weil ich krieg es nicht raus vom MQTT Server ob das jetzt verarbeitet
ist oder nicht. Aber wenn ich das jetzt mache dann funktioniert das gleich. Be right in
Rust. Guck jetzt funktioniert es. Jetzt hat es funktioniert. Man muss dann Delay dazwischen
machen. Wir machen das jetzt mal Multithreaded. Weil warum nicht? Also Multithreaded das heißt
wir erstellen den Krämpel nicht hier sondern wir erstellen den Krämpel hier unten und
dann Multithreaded. Okay lass mal kurz überlegen. Also wir brauchen einen Channel wo wir den
Kram reinschreiben können. Channel ist seit C Sharp 6 oder 5 oder so dabei. Ist schon eine
Weile und ist jetzt der neueste Multithreading Shit den man verwenden soll zwischen Interthread
Communication Unbounded. Was brauchen wir denn überhaupt? Was müssen wir an Infos von da
in nach hier unten dann bekommen? ID und Value oder? Sonst nix. Also Key Value Pair reicht
dafür. String String. So Moment dann kommt der ganze Krämpel weg. Oder? Ich bin auch
verwirrt. Passt das? Mal gucken. So Channel, Writer, Add. Ne Write. Try Write meinetwegen
das ist anbauen bis der Ram voll ist. Meinung zu MBA Absolventen in der IT Branche. Was
ist ein MBA? Bachelor? Oftdings. Was ist MBA? MBA. Was ist MBA? Master of Business. Ach
Master kein Bachelor. Ein Master of Business Administration. Äh wenn du Ahnung hast warum
nicht? Wie kommt es dazu dass du mehr Bock auf IT als auf BWL Müll hast? Gut es ist
BWL Müll das wundert mich nicht dass du mehr Bock auf IT hast aber naja warum nicht? Wenn
du Ahnung hast sprich doch überhaupt nix dagegen. Deine Wirtschaft ist halt richtiger
richtiger Pains Jamp. So die ID wollen wir übergeben und den Payload wollen wir übergeben
ok. Und jetzt kommt Sixhead Time jetzt machen wir hier unten Channel, Reader, Read All,
Async, For Each. Ne ne ne Moment Moment Moment nicht For Each. Parallel, For Each, Channel,
Reader. Oder Read All, Async. Aha das funktioniert damit gar nicht. Ha. Debated. Lul. Äh das
ist natürlich crap. Oder funktioniert es doch? Ey funktioniert doch ich hab nix gesagt. Ok.
So und jetzt können wir das ProThread einmal starten. Schonmal Arch Installer getestet
klar sogar im Stream. So und jetzt machen wir das hier drin was ich machen wollte vorher
also. All die wir anpacken das pass mal auf jetzt kommt High IQ Shit. Moment wie geht
das jetzt nochmal? Wie anpackt man das? Ähm irgendwie so ne? All die Payload. Ja genau.
Oh wir können wir können Leute Sixhead Time pass mal auf. Wir müssen mal neue Features
verwenden. Pass mal auf. Richtig richtig High IQ. Wir verwenden kein Key Value Pair. Wir
verwenden ein Named Topel. Ähm da weiß ich die Sündtags. Das benutzt man so selten da
weiß ich die Sündtags gar nicht dafür. String. ID. Ne. Ähm. Ach du Scheiße wie ist das?
ID? String? Ne. ID? Hey so. So ist richtig. Das funktioniert. Aber da heißt es Item 1
und Item 2. Erkennt das? Erkennt er das hier noch? Guck mal der erkennt das, dass es ID
und Payload ist. Guck mal. Jetzt kann ich nämlich so da drauf zugreifen. ID und Payload.
Named Topel. Das verwende ich nie. Das verwende ich wirklich nie normalerweise. Aber wenn
es geht. Warum nicht? Guck mal er geht schon komplett kaputt hier unten im Sündtags Highlighting.
Payload. Nice. So und jetzt können wir. Guck mal und jetzt machen wir das Multithreaded.
Guck mal jetzt jetzt jetzt läuft das. Jetzt sollte das funktionieren. For each Async.
Hub IT Moment was? Hub IT im Bachelor und danach ein Master of Business Administration
angehangen. Warum nicht? Sprich doch überhaupt nichts dagegen. Sprich doch überhaupt nichts
dagegen. Mir ist das egal ob irgendjemand was mit Business gelernt hat oder nicht. Ich
habe auch mal angefangen Business Zeug zu lernen. Hab dann keinen Bock mehr gehabt.
Was? Hey ich habe in der Hauptschule eine eigene Website designt mit den gleichen Codes
oder whatever. Was? Wie whatever? Mit den gleichen Codes oder whatever? Ist das Programmieren
ähnlich? Also genauso langweilig oder ganz anders? Gut nachdem es whatever ist ich habe
keine Ahnung was du gemacht hast aber wenn du eine Website designt hast vielleicht auch
noch mit solchem Ding wie Frontpage oder sowas dann ist das nicht Programmieren und das ist
auch nicht Programmieren ähnlich. Hättest du jetzt eine interaktive Website mit JavaScript
gemacht dann hätte ich gesagt ja natürlich das ist Programmieren. In Frontpage ein paar
Bilder rein tracken und droppen und das Word an lila machen nicht. Also es ist ganz anders
ob es langweilig ist oder nicht das kann ich dir nicht sagen ob du das langweilig oder
nicht langweilig findest. Aber du bist gifted talent by god also dir müsste eigentlich
alles einfach fallen. Funktioniert oder? Ich glaube es klappt alles. So jetzt läuft
das ganze auch multithreaded. Hoffe ich mal dass das multithreaded läuft. Ja schauen wir
mal. Ähm wir machen hier noch ein paar Debug Ausgaben. Null eins muss ja Bescheid wissen.
Null zwei und das ist null drei alles klar. Run. Beste Debug Ausgaben so macht man es
Leute also wenn ihr irgendwo Bewerbungsgespräche habt und die Frage wie könnt ihr am besten
den Ablauf eines Programms nachvollziehen dann sagt ihr console write line null. Wait a minute
hängt das? Leute hängt das? Hängt das? Das ist multithreaded kaputt. Nochmal ausfüllen
einfach oft genug ausfüllen dann gehts schon irgendwann. Siehst du ne what the fuck? Warum
hängt das? Ich mache überhaupt keinerlei irgendwie kritisches multithreading zeug.
Das hier sollte ja multithreading safe sein. NQ Async. Hoffe ich mal. Ne es muss Leute
das muss thread safe sein weil sonst wäre mir der 4er Champ schon die ganze Zeit abgekackt.
Guck mal da mache ich exakt das gleiche. Hier nur mit deutlich mehr mit 250 Sensoren parallel
mache ich das. Also hä warum hängt das denn? Frontpage wahrscheinlich also das war fast
das gleiche mit insert. Ja keine Ahnung an deiner Beschreibung kann ich jetzt nicht
erkennen was du da gemacht hast. So wie ich das bei nee das glaube ich nicht dass das
mit frontpage das gleiche war was ich da mache. Du musst nicht die also die Programmiersprache
auswendig lernen ist der falsche Ansatz. Du musst verstehen was du machst. Ich weiß
das ist schwierig ich erinnere nur mal an Herr Endpunkt der hatte auch so seine Probleme
mit nachvollziehen auswendig lernen konnte er ganz gut aber das bringt dir nichts. Du
musst dir so ein paar Schlüsselwörter merken aber du musst dir vor allem im Kopf das checken
wie du halt ja bestimmte Sachen machst. Also nicht einfach ich programmiere das und dann
copypaste ich das immer oder hab das auswendig gelernt dann kann ich alles mitmachen nee
so einfach ist das nicht. Du musst lernen wie die Sprache funktioniert und dann musst
du das halt anwenden auch die Probleme die du hast deswegen sage ich ja auch immer wieder
das Programmieren eine kreative Tätigkeit ist. Das ist weniger mit einfachem wir schaffen
jetzt was von A nach B und schalten unser Hirn aus zu tun sondern es ist eine kreative
Sache. Also du hast irgendein Problem und du musst dir überlegen wie kann ich dieses
Problem so weit zerstöckeln und mit den Möglichkeiten die mir die Programmiersprache bietet lösen
und das geht nicht per copypaste oder auswendig gelernt das einzige copypaste was geht ist
von stackoverflow runter kopieren ja. Nee das funktioniert nicht. Leute hat irgendjemand
einen Plan warum das hängt? Das kann ich hängen. Das ist unmöglich dass das hängt.
Mein anderes Programm hängt auch nicht und das macht viel mehr Sensoren. Ja GitHub Copilot
ist so ein Ding. Ich bin froh dass es das bei der Endpunkt noch nicht gegeben hat. S-Tray
wirklich wirklich S-Tray Leute jetzt gehts los. Es wird S-Tray aber dazu muss man das
erstmal bilden. Self-contained release Single File Linux publish minus Self-contained publish
Single File Build. Ich kann nicht mehr Lulz. Es hängt hier dazwischen. Also am Jason Pass
wird es ja wohl kaum liegen. Wir müssen das übrigens noch in try-catch packen sehe ich
da gerade. Das sollten wir wahrscheinlich noch machen. Sollten das noch in try-catch packen.
Ob das wir sehen oder das kaputt geht. So. Build. S-Trays. Wie? Hände mal drauf. Brauchen
wir hier nicht oft. S-Tray weiß gar nicht wie gut das mit.NET funktioniert. Ok es hängt.
Moment ne es hat noch gar nicht angefangen. Es hat noch gar nicht angefangen. Der Futex.
Hat jetzt funktioniert. Leute S-Trays ist broken. Bei.NET. Nix S-Trays. Wundert mich
warum ist das broken. Es müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren. Jetzt hängt es. Guckt es hängt
hier. Was ich mache. Ich versuche was von IO Broker zu Home Assistant rüber zu schieben
und das funktioniert auch. Warum habe ich keine S-Trays Ausgabe mehr. Kann es sein
dass ich meine S-Trays irgendwie überschreibe mit einem Console Write Line und Zeug. Sollte
ich die S-Trays ausgabe. Vielleicht ändert sich die Pit. Wobei warum sollte sich die
Pit ändern. Ja anscheinend ist mit S-Trays nix. Warum geht S-Trays mit.NET nicht. Was
zum. Kann das sein. Dass es einfach die Ausgabe. Dass das die Ausgabe buggt. Wenn ich jetzt
heule. Ich habe keine Ahnung warum S-Trays nicht tut. Wir können es einfach mal so starten.
So. Dann suchen wir danach. Crab. Home Assistant. Da ist er. Pit. Und dann sagen wir S-Trays
nicht. Okay. Der hängt irgendwo da. Nee. Macht er nicht. Das ist das erste. Okay ich
habe keine Ahnung warum S-Trays nicht funktioniert. Kein Plan. Er denkt das sollte funktionieren.
Aber es hängt auf jeden Fall. Und wenn es hängt. Ist schlecht. Ja klar warum nicht.
Nee ohne Mist. Warum bietet es sich daran. Ich persönlich hätte keinen Bock auf irgendwelche
Projektmanagement Geschichten. Weiß ich nicht wie es bei dir aussieht. Da suchen die immer
Leute und ich kann dir sagen Projektmanager die wenigstens ein bisschen was von Technik
verstehen sind auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht. Nee warum nicht. Bietet es sich doch an in
dem Fall. Ganz im Ernst. Es werden so viele Leute aktuell gesucht. Ich denke du wirst
auf jeden Fall jemand finden. Gerade wenn du. Du hast ja auch. Du hast dein Master bestimmt
nicht umsonst gemacht. Also du wirst bestimmt was gescheites finden. JST LAN. Dankeschön
für den Sub. Dankeschön Leute übrigens für die ganzen Subs heute. Ich glaube ich
habe nicht ein vorgelesen. Low IQ nicht Vollis. Lesender Subs. Game Shock. Dankeschön. Gar
nicht gesehen. King Cartman am Start. Arso. Mr. Moo Game. Aralion. Der Sebaro. Den habe
ich ja ganz übersehen. Cute Mod himself ist wieder am Start. Wie läuft es bei dir
eigentlich im Studio Sebaro falls du noch da bist. Clown27 Doomswap. Dankeschön Leute
für die ganzen Subs heute. Massive Subscriptions. Mache jetzt wieder viel Mate MonkaS. Wie lang
brauchst du noch. Wann bist du fertig. Ok aus irgendwelchen Gründen hängt der Kram
hier und ich weiß nicht warum. Chat sag mir mal warum es hängt. Multithreading Shit.
Warum hängt das. Ok wo hängt das. Es hängt eigentlich hauptsächlich immer bei den MQTT
net Dingern. Also dann gucken wir doch mal in den Source Code was da passiert. NQ Async.
MQTT net GitHub. Sind die da Threadsave. Kann man den Threadsave verwenden. Ich weiß man
kann den Threadsave verwenden weil der Vier Champ verwendet den Threadsave. So eineinhalb
Jahre bis zur Bachelor Arbeit. Nice. Dann hast du es ja zur Hälfte geschafft jetzt.
Client. Was muss ich denn hier suchen. MQTT Client. NQ Async. Irgendwas mit Q. Boah fremden
Source Code durchgucken man. Publish Packet Receiver MQ Async Q. Ok ich muss mich da
anderweitig lang hangeln. NQ Async. Navigate to. Implementation. Manage Client. NQ Async.
Aha. Macht er hier. Wait. Message Q. Lock. Leute das Deadlocked sich garantiert irgendwie.
Hast du dir schon mal Jetbrains Space angeschaut. Ne. Zebaro Zebaro Zebaro jetzt wo du da bist.
Hast du dir das wirklich ernsthaft überlegt mit Lehrer werden. Also Kinder und Jugendliche
ist doch das abgefuckteste was es gibt. Also die gehen ja doch permanent auf den Sack.
Oder. Also ernsthaft. Ich könnte ich könnte ich könnte nicht ich könnte nicht mit. Mit
Kindern und Jugendlichen und und den Leuten in der Schule was. Das geht wirklich. Der
Zebaro haut da bestimmt voll auf den Tisch. Was wird hier schon wieder Handy geguckt.
Dann nimmt das Handy und erst mal. Da ist bestimmt richtig richtig. Gehasst. Da kommt
er wieder. Hab ja während Corona viel in der Schule gearbeitet. Ja gut dann weißt
er aber oft nicht sich einlässt. Wenn ihr Lehramt grillst. Ja irgendeinen Vorteil muss
es ja haben. Der Zebaro da führt das bestimmt hier mit eiserner Hand. Da gibt es da gibt
es keinen da gibt es nichts zu lachen. Wie du bist in der fünften Klasse und weißt noch
nicht wie man Placingly fast mit Rust was programmiert. 5. C++ 6. Berufsschule Leute
wenn ich mir das angucke in der Berufsschule was da für Leute rum gesessen haben bei mir
in der Klasse. Das ist fast noch schlimmer Berufsschule. Generell Schule ist kacke.
Also für mich. Ich hätte gar keinen Bock drauf. Bestimmte Branche empfehlen oder abraten
nicht wirklich. Also ich arbeite in der Bank in Frankfurt. Das kann ich jetzt nicht so
empfehlen aktuell. Wobei das eher an dem Laden liegt und nicht so generell an der Finanzbranche.
Finanzbranche ist halt ganz viel geschwätzt. Die feiern sich da immer unglaublich ab. Es
feiern sich alle Unternehmen ab. Leute hat irgendjemand schon mal bei einem Unternehmen
gearbeitet das sich nicht selbst abgefeiert hat. Ich glaube das gibt es nicht. Aber im
Finanz- bzw. auch im Finanz-Dienstleistungssektor die feiern sich richtig krass ab. Consulting
hat gefeiert. Ja das stimmt. Die auch. Aber ansonsten kann ich da nichts gescheites empfehlen
jetzt. Wait Async was macht denn das? Leute die deadlocken sich hier irgendwie. Guck
mal der hat auch kein Cancellation Token. Das backt hier irgendwie rum. Das backt irgendwie
rum und. Hab ich denn die gleiche Version? Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir doch mal. Hab ich
denn die gleiche Version bei mir? Ich hab MQTTnet 4.11318 und was verwendet der Fiat
Champ? Was verwendet der Fiat Champ? Weil da geht Multithreading. Wo ist denn mein Projekt
da? Der verwendet. Aha guck dir mal. Der verwendet eine ältere Version. 4.10247 MonkaW Aha aha
dann wollen wir mal. Wollen wir das mal downcrate auf 4.10247. Downcrate. What? Ja komm geh mal
weg da unten. Was willst du von mir? Das da muss man downcrate. Excellent. Wait a minute
sollte der das hier auch downcrate? Ok Package down gecrate. Pass mal auf jetzt wirds funktionieren
easy. Ne Moment das sei jetzt immer noch kompiliert. Run. So. Ja. Es hängt nix. Hängt nix. Alles
durch. Die haben nen Bug. Ich führ nochmal aus. Die haben nen Bug. Die haben irgendeinen
Multithreading Bug in der neuesten Version drinne. Bin halt etwas aufgeregt weil das mein
erster Fulltime Job wäre. Das willst du nicht wirklich. Glaub mir. Das willst du wahrscheinlich
nicht. Was heißt glaub mir? Ist jetzt nicht so als hätt ich da gearbeitet. Ganz im Ernst
es hat nen Grund warum Google, Facebook, Amazon die Leute nach nem Jahr im Durchschnitt abhauen.
Das ist doch nicht so geil wie sie sich vorgestellt haben. Klar ein paar bleiben da aber im Durchschnitt
sind die knapp über nen Jahr da. Warum? Weil es ultra stressig ist und ultra äh wie soll
man sagen? Elbung, Competitive und No Life 24 7. Also ich glaube kaum einer will das
wirklich. Es denken zwar viele sie wollens und im Lebenslauf macht sich in ja Google
sicherlich gut. Aber lang Zeit will das keiner. So easy. Bug gefunden. Wir müssen einfach
die ältere Version von MQTT net verwenden. Wir können jetzt mal bei denen in den Sourcecode
gucken. Was haben die denn hier angestellt? Zeig mal her. Managed MQTT client brauche
ich. Managed, wo ist denn das überhaupt? Managed MQ, wo liegt denn das hier im Repo?
Managed MQTT client. Managed MQTT nee wo ist denn das? Managed MQTT client. So und dann
waren wir irgendwie MQ? Ja. Oh da suchen wir mal nach. Ok also da haben die irgendwas dran
geändert in letzter Zeit. Guck mal vom 5. April. Fuck. Die haben nix geändert. Moment
vielleicht doch. Wann von wann ist denn die Version die geht und von wann ist die Version
die nicht geht? Ok komm mal es wurde vor einer Stunde. Leute der Bug ist gefixt in der neuesten
Version und wir sind reingerannt. Null. Guckt euch das mal an. Was ein Piss man. Alter.
Das musste er erst mal schaffen. Meinst du der hat stream geschaut? Ist das ein deutscher?
Egal. Germany. Wait a minute. Wann haben wir das festgestellt das es hängt? Ach nee der
hat nur die Version released. 8.15. Nee nee das war Zufall. Nee das war Zufall da haben
wir also nicht entdeckt das es hängt. Da haben wir nur nicht entdeckt das es hängt. Ist
das Nougat Package denn schon da? Hier ist das Nougat Package. Vorhin hatten wir das?
Jetzt gibt es das hier. Ok Upgrade. Gebe ihm. Upgrade. Easy. Also 20.15 ist Zufall das haben
wir noch nicht gefunden zu dem Zeitpunkt mit dem Deadlock. Gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert.
See Stream sniped. Jetzt gehts wieder. Nice. Ok schauen wir mal was er da gemacht hat.
Was denn jetzt eigentlich das Problem war. Picks freezes in SS und Deadlock. Darf ich
fragen wie oft hast du deinen Job gewechselt? So gut wie gar nicht. Ich hab meine Ausbildung
gemacht bei einem Provider. Ich hab ein paar Jahre danach noch beim Provider gearbeitet.
Und dann bin ich gewechselt zur Bank in Frankfurt und da bin ich seitdem jetzt. Ich hab dieses
Jahr 10 jähriges Jubiläum. Und es ist passend dazu suche ich gerade einen neuen Job. Also
insofern 10 Jahre reicht. Aber das ist nicht wegen 10 Jahren sondern weil mir andere Sachen
auf den Keks gehen. Also das mit dem Jobwechsel steht fest. Ne so wie 100% nicht fest steht
da nix. So wie ich es gesagt hab im Video. Wenn sich was gutes ergibt und sich bei mir
in der Firma wo ich arbeite nix tut. Sowohl Homeoffice technisch als auch vielleicht bisschen
Gehaltstechnisch. Dann nehme ich das andere an zum Ende des Jahres. Ich hab ja vorhin gerade
noch mit einem Ex-Kollege telefoniert. Der quasi meint sie haben einen Job für mich.
Und letztens im Stream als wir Jobanzeigen geguckt haben da hatte ich instant 3 Jobangebote
danach und ich hab noch nicht mal gesucht großartig. Also insofern passt schon. Wie kam es eigentlich
dazu dass so ein Märchenjahr ein Homeoffice. Ah ja weil wir Absolut Boomer Management haben
die da Meinung sind man kann nur ordentlich managen wenn die Leute da sind. Und ich hab
das mehrfach an allen möglichen. Sie müssen sich wirklich nicht wundern wenn ich abhaue.
Ich hab das an ganz vielen Stellen mehrfach schon gesagt dass ich das nicht mit mache
lange. Und dass mir es extrem auf den Sack geht. Und ich hab meinem Chef sogar erzählt
ich suche aktuell schon nach neuen Stellen. Also was soll ich machen. Also aus heiterem
Himmel kommt es nicht. Und die haben sich jetzt überlegt man soll halt wieder 2 Tage die
Woche anwesend sein. Also sprich ich arbeite ja nur Teilzeit. Ich arbeite ja nur 4 Tage
die Woche. Und sowohl 5 Tage die Woche arbeite als auch 4 Tage die Woche arbeite sollen jeweils
2 Tage kommen. Also nicht irgendwie anhand der Arbeitszeit. Find ich auch schon sehr
unfair. Zumal es überhaupt nichts bringt außer mich abzufacken mit der Bahn. Und dass ich
weniger arbeite. Also wie gesagt sollte ich mag die Leute wirklich dort. Nicht wie gesagt
nicht jeden. Es gibt aber so 4-5 Leute die mag ich wirklich. Also mit denen verstehe ich
mich gut und die sind mir wirklich ans Herz geweiht. So der Felix zum Beispiel mit dem
hab ich sogar schon mal ein Video aufgenommen. Von der Gamescom mit dem war ich bei der Gamescom
damals. Gibt noch mehr. Felix kennt ihr halt aus irgendwelche Videos von damals vielleicht
noch. Ja und eigentlich will ich da nicht weg. Aber ganz im Ernst wenn die mir so offen
Kicks gehen ich muss mir halt irgendwann überlegen was ist mir wichtiger. Und es ist halt so
Homeoffice ist bei mir ich schaffe im Prinzip mehr und mir geht es besser dabei. Also und
ich kann auch mehr Content machen für euch weil ich früher daheim bin. Also es ist eigentlich
für euch am besten für mich am besten und für die Firma am besten. Mehr als sagen kann
ich es nicht. Wenn die nicht wollen kann ich ihnen auch nicht helfen. Ja das wäre in Ordnung
ja da hätte ich kein Problem. Ich würde sogar einen Tag die Woche machen. Einen Tag
die Woche wäre in Ordnung. Das kann ich mir mal geben. Das würde ich dann entweder Dienstags
oder Freitags machen dann ist gut. Das würde ich tatsächlich machen. Dann sieht man die
Leute alles in Ordnung. Aber zwei Tage. Da sind 50% von meinen vier Tagen. Also es ist
einfach richtiger Abfuck. Ich mache ja in den Tagen im Büro noch nicht mal großartig
was. Ich miete da ein bisschen. Schwätze mit den Leuten. Guck mir irgendwas an. Wirklich
arbeiten kann ich im Büro gar nicht. Verglichen mit wie gut das daheim klappt ja. Richtig
richtig. Montags darfst du Homeoffice machen. Montags. Ich weiß wie du es meinst aber für
alle weil sie es wahrscheinlich nicht alle wissen. Ich arbeite ja montags nicht. Also
ich arbeite Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag, Freitag. Montags habe ich frei. Das weiß
der. Nein der sieht das genauso wie ich. Der sieht es ganz genauso wie ich. Dass es besser
ist im Homeoffice. Und bei mir kann sich wirklich keiner beschweren. Ich mache so viel Zeug
und ich mache auch teilweise so viel Zeug freiwillig und kümmere mich um so viel Zeug
wo sonst keiner irgendwie was macht. Es kann sich bei mir wirklich niemand beschweren
dass ich die Zeit da irgendwie nicht sinnvoll nutzen würde. Letztens freiwillig sogar noch
Präsentation gehalten die super angekommen ist. Also die können sich wirklich nicht
beschweren was die dafür kriegen. Aber wenn sie halt keinen Bock drauf haben dann soll
ich machen. Da kann ich ihnen nicht helfen. Da muss ich mir selbst helfen. Freitag halber
Tag. Ne ne montags bin ich nicht da. Freitags ist meistens so 14.30 Uhr oder so meistens
Schluss. Moment lief der Campbell jetzt eigentlich. Lass mal kurz gucken was hat er denn hier
gefixt. Was hat er denn hier gefixt. Ganz schön viel. Hier hat er wahrscheinlich was
gefixt. Hier Completed Instance from Results. Enter Async. Wait. Wait Async ist. Leute wisst
ihr was ich geil finde. Ich war exakt an der gleichen Stelle wo ich gesagt habe hier deadlockt
sich irgendwo. Was ist denn das für ein Zufall man. Wir haben parallel gerade irgendwie den
Kram angeguckt. Vielleicht war er doch im Stream. Ich kann es mir gerade nicht anders
erklären aber 20.15 Uhr ist eigentlich. Wir haben das erst später entdeckt. Oder ich
habe das Zeitgefühl komplett verloren. Oder mein Github Moment. Ne guck mal der hatte
schon vor zwei Tagen gefixt. Der hatte schon vor zwei Tagen gefixt. Da garantiert nicht.
Der hat schon vor zwei Tagen gefixt. Witzig. Witzig oder. Also das ist wirklich Zufall
man. So dann machen wir hier nochmal ein Log. Log Information. Oder sagen wir jetzt Published.
State Topic. Config Topic. Rest ist egal. Es reicht super. So und jetzt machen wir abschließend
einen Test ob alles funktioniert. Zack. Und Run. Au. Unbekannt.
Habe ich zu schnell. Habe ich den Value zu schnell gepusht. Hast du eigentlich den ganzen
ApoRed Shitstorm mitbekommen. Du meinst das mit Genshin Impact. Ich habe das Sponsoring
gesehen von ApoRed. Das fand ich jetzt. Ja. Also ganz im Ernst. Es gibt schlimmeres.
Ja. Oh Leute es ist kaputt. Ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht. Lull. Nicht nur das. Ok.
Nee was war denn. Erzählt. Erzähl Leute was war. Ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Unbekannt. Luftdaten. Irgendwas. Oh ich habe ich weiß was ich gemacht habe. Ich habe hier
irgendwas. Irgendwas. Irgendwas habe ich hier umformatiert. Und das hat es kaputt gemacht.
Guck mal hier. Da. Da sind auf einmal Leerzeichen drinnen. Das hat Rider. Rider hat es kaputt
gemacht. Lull. Guck mal Rider hat es zerstört. Jetzt stimmt nämlich das Topic nicht mehr.
So. Kurz schauen. Aha. Jetzt funktioniert es. Guck mal. Direkt alle Daten rübergepumpt
von Home Assistant. Von. Von der Home Assistant. So mag ich das. Ja. Und jetzt könnten wir
auch mal gucken. Haben wir irgendwo noch ein bisschen mehr Daten. Ja. Ich könnte einfach
mal alles rüber packen oder. Alles hier. Dass da ein bisschen mehr. Ein bisschen mehr
drinne ist. Ja. Alles. Den ganzen. Den ganzen Krempel packe ich jetzt hier rüber. So.
Admin. Alles. Also Instances. MQTT. Können wir einfach sagen. Kann man einfach sagen
Sternchen oder Published. Alles. Geht das? Schauen wir mal. Anscheinend. Anscheinend.
Guck mal. Honst. Nur dass der. Alter der aktualisiert jetzt jede Sekunde weil die Zeit hochzählt.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel des Guten. Jede Sekunde. Aber ey ich mein das funktioniert.
Wir haben den kompletten. Wir haben den kompletten. Na ja. Home Assistant. Ich meine die Uhrzeit
wird halt jetzt jede Sekunde geschickt. Das ist bisschen zu. Es ist vielleicht ein bisschen
zu übertrieben. Aber es funktioniert. Ja man könnte. Man könnte noch ein Sleep machen.
Guck mal. Man könnte noch sagen. Ne. Können wir überhaupt sinnvoll ein Sleep da drin machen.
Ne wir können gar keinen sinnvollen Sleep da drin machen. Aber es funktioniert. Das
ist gut. Haben wir unser Ziel erreicht. Also. Oh fuck. Das ist zu spät. Er ist Bankrott
lebt von Hartz IV und tut nur aufreich. Ne dass er. Dass er den Insie Modus gestartet
hat. Das habe ich mitgekriegt. Tut nur aufreich. Macht er das überhaupt. Ganz davon abgesehen
ihr könnt davon ausgehen dass die meisten Leute die aufreich tun tatsächlich auch nur
tun. Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel. Ja gibt es sicherlich welche. Aber die meisten sind
irgendwelche Leute wie Karl S. Oder sowas. Die dir dann erzählen wollen. Mach in meinem
Schneeballsystem mit dann wirst du reich wie ich. Krasse krasse Lifestyle in keine Ahnung
am Strand auf Teneriffa und und sonst was weiß ich nicht alles gibt. Die meisten die
ganz potzig sind und raushängen lassen sind nicht die die wirklich die Kohle haben.
Krasse Lifestyle im FFM Plattenbau. Kommt ja aus Frankfurt. Ne oder. Wo kommt wo kommt
ein Apo Red her. Hamburg. Ah ok. Tja Leute aber zum Thema Reich und nicht. Ich komme
aus Frankfurt ja. Und vielleicht auch im Plattenbau ihr wisst ja nicht wie mein Haus wie das ausschaut
hier also vielleicht noch gar nicht mein Haus. Vergesst was ich sagen wollte. Ach so ja zum
Thema Reich und so. Nächstes Video ist Battlefield wieder mit Sellout. Sellout für irgend so
ein komisches Mobile Game. Weil Money. Und es wird richtig cringe Placement wieder kann
ich euch sagen. Ich habe euch ja vorhin mal einen Satz daraus vorgelesen ich frage mich
wer dieses Skript immer schreibt. Mal kurz nachgucken. Raid. Nein. Nicht Raid Shadow
Visions. Irgend so ein komischer Peggle Clown. Irgendein komischer Peggle Clown. Ich habe
mir das Game angeguckt. Es ist halt ein Mobile Game. Jeder der Spaß an sowas hat hat da vielleicht
Spaß dran keine Ahnung. Aber ich mein mir ist das wurscht. Also das traue ich den Leuten
zu dass sie in der Lage sind bevor sie dann Millionen für ausgeben das sich selbst zu
überlegen und es nicht nur machen weil ich das in dem Video gesagt habe. Ich lese euch
noch mal ein cringe Satz aus dem Sponsoring vor Sekunde. Es muss sein jetzt sind mehr
Leute da. Also wie gesagt ein Satz aus meinem Skript für das Sponsoring. Entdecke deine
Wetteifer Seite und Spiele Turniere um epische Preise zu gewinnen. Wetteifer Seite. Hat das
wirklich irgendjemand schon wirklich mal so gesagt. Wetteifer Seite. Das ist doch keine
Wort Kombination normalerweise verwendet oder. Hab ich noch nie gehört. Was soll das sein.
Wirklicher Sprach Gebrauche. Aber es soll mir. Soll mir. Soll mir. Soll mir. Recht sein.
Wen juckts. Easy Money. Wisst ihr noch wo alle am Anfang 2000. Wann war das. 2011 12 rum
gesagt haben. Ich werde nie YouTube Partner werden. Ich habe das auch gesagt übrigens.
Aber fast jeder gesagt. Aha. Warum eigentlich. Was warum wir das damals gesagt haben oder
warum ich Partner geworden bin. Also kann ich dir beides beantworten gesagt haben wir
das weil für uns Partner werden was furchtbar verwerflich. Es war für viele. Ja weil das
was weil das war super verwerflich. Es war so man macht den Content nicht rein aus Spaß
und Luft und Liebe sondern weil man Geld damit verdienen will. Das war in der damaligen Zeit
total fremder Gedanke irgendwie dass man mit Content Geld verdienen kann oder beziehungsweise
es hatte fast so was unehrenhaftes unethisches mit mit Content Geld zu verdienen. Es ist andere
Zeiten gewesen. Heute sagen die Leute wenn du sie in der Grundschule fragst was möchtest
du später werden dann sagen die Influencer. Es ist komplett. Es ist erst das ist zehn
Jahre her. Aber es hat sich in diesen zehn Jahren extrem viel geändert in dieser Richtung.
Heute ist das ein Traumberuf von vielen Kindern Jugendlichen die wollen Influencer werden.
Ein paar schaffen es vielleicht auch. Gibt ja immer kommen immer wieder neue nach. Einer
cringiger als der Andi aber es kommen immer neue Leute nach. Ja und bei den meisten klappt
es natürlich nicht. Ja und warum ich es dann gemacht habe ganz einfach weil ich Geld verdienen
wollte damit. Weil ich dachte mir ich gebe mir ja schon also geht ja auch viel von der
Zeit flöten. Und warum sollte ich nicht damit was verdienen. Ich muss mal kurz was gucken.
Waren eigentlich die Twitch Follower. Wubblers. Der Wubblers hat Followerbots gekriegt. Ne
die Followerbots sind wieder weg. Kackel. Komm mal Twitch hat die Followerbots gelöscht.
Irgendjemand hat mich gebotet vor ein paar Tagen. Die sind wieder alle weg. Jetzt bin
ich wieder bei 23.787. Nö. Mein neuer Chef guckt meine Videos auch nicht. Und außerdem
alles das was ich im Video gesagt habe habe ich ihm auch gesagt. Das weiß der ja schon
seit nichts Neues. Ich hab dem ja sogar eins zu eins gesagt. Ich guck mich jetzt um nach
neuen Sachen. Also wie gesagt ich kann dem Laden da nicht helfen. Wenn die keinen Bock
haben da drauf. Ich kann ja schlecht sagen ihr müsst das jetzt machen. Wenn die das
nicht wollen dann kann ich mir da nur selbst helfen und was anderes suchen. Morgen muss
ich übrigens mit der Bahn fahren wieder. Das wird wieder was. Ich schau mal kurz im
zweiten Tab. Ich lasse euch jetzt nicht mitgucken ob mein Zug morgen früh fährt. Nö. Nicht
ab 19 Uhr. Ab 9 Uhr. Ab 7 Uhr soll ich gucken. Wichtige Informationen in den Verbindungsdetails.
Ok. Art entfällt. Alter ihr Dreck. Ne ich sag jetzt nichts sonst werde ich wirklich.
Was followbots hab ich was vergessen wieder. Oh ne. Come on please. Nicht schon wieder.
Mein Zug fällt morgen aus. Sag mal was ist das denn. Was. Ne ich kann mich jetzt sonst
kann ich nicht pennen wenn ich mich jetzt aufrege. Das kann doch nicht sein. Dienstag
ausgefallen. Freitag ausgefallen. Und jetzt wieder. Was machen die denn. Und wisst ihr
was das geilste ist ich zeige euch mal was. Ich hatte. Ich mach mal kurz die Follower
aus. Kann Twitch dann wieder remove. Ich hasse die Bahn auch. Guckt mal. YouTube. Hier.
Da war einer der bei der Bahn arbeitet richtig richtig böse auf mich. Dass ich die Bahn
so schlecht geredet hab. Wo ist er denn. Ok jetzt ist irgendwas worauf ich geantwortet
hab. Man kann halt auf YouTube immer gescheit suchen. Kennt ihr noch die Zeiten wo man tatsächlich
Kommentare suchen konnte und mit der Page unten. Der Zugvogel hat nämlich was geschrieben
hier auf. Guck mal. Riesen Wall of Text. Reg dich so viel über die Bahn auf wie du
willst. Aber machs erst mal besser. Das ist ja was was mich prinzipiell immer wahnsinnig
überzeugt. Ja machs erst mal besser. Ich kann auch kein Smartphone bauen und kann
trotzdem bestimmte Funktionen an Smartphones blöd finden. Machs erst mal besser. Ich kann
Battlefield 2042 auch kacke finden und kein besseres Battlefield programmieren können.
Also die Möglichkeit etwas wirklich besser zu machen und was schlecht zu finden sind zwei
komplett unterschiedliche Passure. Machs erst mal besser mit den Mitteln die einem
der Bund zur Verfügung stellt. Das sind nämlich im Gegensatz bla bla bla. Ja der hat ja recht
aber es ist mir scheiß egal. Das soll einfach funktionieren. Weil wenn es nicht funktioniert
dann sind sie überflüssig. Wäre mal gespannt wie du das wuppen würdest. Das ist überhaupt
nicht der Punkt. Wahrscheinlich genauso wenig. Wahrscheinlich genauso wenig. Ja das hat ja
schon seinen Grund warum es nicht läuft. Aber das ist das was geändert werden muss. Das
funktioniert. Da muss ich mir doch keine Gedanken drum machen als jemand der das einfach nur
in Anspruch nehmen will. Ja und das und dann sagt er das in der App alles stimmt. Welche
gefakte Statistik in der App. In der App wird ja auf die Minute genau das stimmt überhaupt
nicht. Die App ist gelogen zur Hälfte. Züge werden teilweise rausgenommen. Weil so nach
dem Motto wer möchte wissen dass sie Verspätung haben. Aber viel besser ist wenn der Zug angeblich
schon losgefahren ist an deinem Bahnhof und noch gar nicht mal da war. Also laut der App
ist er schon zwei Bahnhöfe weiter aber er war noch gar nicht da. Und irgendwann kommt
dann so ach ups wir haben vergessen er hat ja 20 Minuten Verspätung. Das ist zusammen
gelogenes und gefaktes Zeug. Das habe ich im Endeffekt auch drauf geantwortet. Ja dass
mir das eigentlich vollkommen egal ist wer dafür verantwortlich ist. Ich will den Kram
benutzen. Gerade vor allem ich will den Kram halt auch so benutzen wie er letztendlich irgendwo
auch verkauft wird. Und wenn da steht 7 Uhr fährt ein Zug dann erwarte ich und alles andere
wäre ja auch eine ziemlich blödsinnige Erwartung. Dass der um 7 Uhr auch fährt plus minus 5
Minuten ist in Ordnung da sage ich gar nichts. Das muss plus minus 5 Minuten von A nach B
gebracht werden. Ich bin überhaupt nicht anspruchsvoll Leute. Ich will ich will kein Klo im Zug ich
brauche nichts zu essen im Zug. Ich brauche theoretisch noch nicht mal Sitzplätze im Zug.
Ich brauche eigentlich fast nichts. Ich brauche kein WLAN im Zug. Ich brauche fast nichts.
Ich brauche einen Zug der von A nach B fährt plus minus 5 Minuten so wie es da steht. Das
ist alles. Und das ist das absolut mindeste was die Bahn machen müsste, leisten müsste
um ihr Dasein zu rechtfertigen zumindest für Personenverkehr. Und das kriegen sie nicht
hin. Und deswegen das ist halt einfach überflüssig so wie es jetzt ist. Gerade in der aktuellen
Zeit wo es Umweltverschmutzungen in den Innenstädten wo sie teilweise auf die Idee kommen wir sie
wollen verbieten dass die Leute mit den Autos in die Innenstädte fahren dürfen. Wie willst
du denn da was verbieten? Was ist denn die Alternative bitteschön? Nicht ankommen? Da
werden sich bestimmt alle Geschäfte und Arbeitgeber wahnsinnig freuen wenn du nicht mehr in die
Stadt fahren darfst. Ja oder es dürfen alle nur noch im Umkreis von paar Kilometer arbeiten
wo jeder einfach mit dem Fahrrad hinfahren kann oder mit dem Roller oder so. Es ergibt
so wie es jetzt ist selbst auf kurze Sicht schon überhaupt keinen Sinn. Die Bahn kann
schlicht und klar nicht das machen wofür sie da ist. Also sie scheitert ja kolossal
da jetzt schon dran aktuell. Und gerade in Zukunft werden jetzt noch mehr auf individuellen
Verkehr gesetzt werden soll und man alles insgesamt ein bisschen umweltfreundlicher
machen will ja dann macht mal die Bahn fit dass das funktioniert. Weil sonst wird das
nix. Wie soll das klappen? Wie soll Leute sollen nicht mehr Auto fahren aber es gibt
keine Alternative bitteschön funktionieren. Frankfurt und Köln sind die Negativbeispiele
naja gut man muss halt mal sagen Frankfurt ist eines der Städte mit dem massig Geld
Frankfurt hängt ja nicht an der Kohle oder so. Und Frankfurt ist eine der wichtigsten
Städte der Welt. Das heißt man kann doch erwarten dass man vom Umland in eine der
wichtigsten Städte der Welt mit dem Nahverkehr kommt. Und das ist einfach nicht der Fall.
Das klappt einfach nicht. Und es ist mir vollkommen egal woran es liegt ja zu wenig
Geld Stau an den Geldern was auch immer ich erwarte dass es funktioniert wenn es nicht
funktioniert sollen die Leute die dafür verantwortlich sind ihre Arbeit erledigen.
Das ist der Grund warum ich nach Frankfurt fahre weil ich auch meine Arbeit erledigen
muss. Und am Ende muss ich irgendwie noch 45 42 sonst was oder keine Ahnung Prozent abgeben
von dem was ich verdiene. Okay mache ich ja prinzipiell sogar gerne das ist ja nicht
so dass ich was dagegen hätte Steuern zu bezahlen. Wenn mit dem Geld halt irgendwas gemacht werden
würde was mir auch was bringt wäre halt noch besser. Also vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht
ich fürchte allerdings dass es dort erstmal auf irgendwelche komischen Reaktionen so Kurzschluss
Reaktionen rauslaufen wird so nach dem Motto wir verbieten jetzt in die Innenstadt zu fahren
mit dem Auto. Alternativen gibt es nicht was juckt es mich denn. Da hätte ich da hätte
ich also letztendlich das traue ich allen zu. Also ich traue keinem zu das zu fixen in der
aktuellen Konstellation. Plus da könnte ich mir vorstellen dass noch ein bisschen mehr
dazu kommt. Es wäre auf jeden Fall cool wenn das also sollte es was bringen. Ja habe ich
nichts gesagt. Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen dass es eher zu solchen auswüchsen führt
wie ja wir machen es jetzt super umweltfreundlich indem wir das das und das verbieten nur dass
man das benutzen muss weil es keine Alternativen gibt. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt also auf
der anderen Seite ich meine es hat sich immerhin jetzt mit der aktuellen Regierung mehr getan
als in die Jahre davor. Also hast du tatsächlich das Gefühl an manchen an manchen Ecken bewegt
sich was. Meint ihr sie kriegen es hin dass es ein 9 Euro Ticket beziehungsweise 69 Euro
49 Euro 89 Euro Ticket gibt. Ich glaube ja nicht. Ich ich ich das ist das ist ich traue
ihnen so die mindesten die mindesten Sachen eigentlich schon nicht zu. Das wäre meiner
Meinung nach wirklich wichtig. Erstens ist die Bahn für das was sie leistet viel viel
zu teuer. Echt haben sie es jetzt beschlossen. Wirklich. Die haben das letzte was ich mitgekriegt
habe ist dass sie beschlossen haben. Das letzte was sie beschlossen haben ist doch dass sie
das jetzt irgendwie auch wirklich sicher auf die Agenda setzen. Die Bild okay die Bild
wollen wir nicht. Okay das habe ich gar nicht. Warum der Nachfolger okay okay okay. Zeig mal
her Mensch sag mal was ist das rot rot 5 oder gibt es vielleicht noch irgendwas wo man den
Kram auch mal normal lesen kann 24 rein. Ja genau.
Alter droht mit einem Bankot. Leute das geht mir so auf den Sack. Jeder meint er muss da
jetzt mal irgendwie mit pissen. 49 Euro ist ein super Preis ich bezahle für mein Job Ticket
deutlich mehr. Ich
bin mal gespannt ob da wirklich irgendwas kommt. Ich habe da noch meine Zweifel ob das
kommt. Die werden das wieder zerreden und am Ende passiert nichts. Ich habe da kein
Vertrauen dass irgendwas passiert. Genau das denke ich mir auch. Das denke ich mir übrigens
jedes Mal wenn eine Durchsage kommt Blablabla Blablabla wir bitten um Entschuldigung Entschuldigung
da denke ich mir auch immer halt die Fresse. Und manchmal sage ich das auch vor mich hin.
Na klar allein schon das zur Arbeit fahren ist billiger. Und wenn du dann noch quasi
billiger Bahn fahren kannst zur Arbeit und dann theoretisch damit auch noch wenn du es
eh schon hast mal in die andere Richtung fahren kannst. Ich fahre beispielsweise total oft
zum wandern und da benutze ich mal gut ich habe jetzt ein Elektroauto mit dem Auto. Da
gibt es durchaus die Möglichkeit zu vielen Stellen zu fahren an den Bahnhof. Und das
ist nach Bayern in die eine Richtung. Und wenn das geht. Da wäre ich dabei. Das würde
ich machen. Das würde ich zumindest mal ausprobieren. Und gerade wenn das Samstag Vormittag ist
oder so und es so kleine Pfurzbahnhöfe sind vielleicht kommt da auch was pünktlich.
Ja wie gesagt ich finde das prinzipiell gut. Und wisst ihr was ich auch gut finde vielleicht
steigt der Druck noch weiter auf die Bahn dadurch dass eben halt auch viele Leute dann
fahren wollen die sonst nicht fahren. Doch da wo ich wandern gehe gibt es teilweise
Bahnhöfe nicht überall aber zum größten Teil gibt es welche. Die müssen den ganzen
Tag und zwar jeden Tag die 24 7 muss die Bahn einen riesen Anschluss bekommen bis es besser
wird sonst wird das nichts. Und vor allem nicht nur Anschlüsse verteilen es muss direkt
persönliche Konsequenzen haben für Bahn Manager und Verantwortliche wenn sie ihren Job nicht
richtig machen. Ich meine ich sage nicht dass man die irgendwie gleich köpfen soll oder
so. Wobei könnte man bei der Bahn vielleicht mal drüber diskutieren aber natürlich sowas
nicht. Aber die müssen schlicht und ergreifend auch nicht so sicher im Sessel sitzen. Wenn
das nicht läuft korrekt korrekt das meine ich ja. Wenn es nicht läuft müssen die rausfliegen
und zwar nicht irgendwie erst nach zwei Jahren oder so. Da muss es ganz klare Auflagen und
Ziele geben. Und wenn das nicht nachvollziehbar passiert NEXT kann doch nicht sein dass du
versagen kannst mehrere Jahre am Stück und du fette Kohle kassierst und dich eigentlich
nichts interessieren musst. Aber solange es da keine persönliche Verantwortung bzw. persönliches
Interesse dran gibt der Bahn Manager und der Bahnverantwortlichen dann wird sich da auch
nichts dran tun. Das frage ich mich ja über viele öffentliche Projekte teilweise ob da
nicht die Anreize schlicht und ergreifend falsch gesetzt sind. Stellt euch mal vor ihr
seid der Projektleiter von einem größeren Projekt. Ihr baut ihr sollt irgendeine Brücke
Flughafen Brücke Bahnhof. Stellt euch mal vor ihr seid der Projektleiter. Ihr braucht
jetzt anstatt 5 Jahre 10 Jahre. Es hat für euch keine negativen Konsequenzen außer dass
ihr euer mega Gehalt 5 Jahre länger sicher habt. Warum sollte man in 5 Jahren fertig
werden? Was ist der Anreiz dazu in 5 Jahren fertig zu werden? Es ist ja nicht euer Geld
was da irgendwie rausgehauen wird. Ihr habt 5 Jahre weiterhin einen super geilen bezahlten
Job. Wo ist der Anreiz pünktlich fertig zu werden? Sicherlich sehe ich das jetzt deutlich
zu vereinfacht aber mich wirds wirklich mal interessieren wo der Anreiz sein soll. Also
warum sollte man als Projektmanager unter diesen Bedingungen nicht einfach total überziehen?
Man gibt ja fette Kohle. Negative Auswirkungen gibt es nicht. Also insofern warum sollte
man rechtzeitig fertig werden? Ja deswegen ja. Ich mein gut du musst ja ab und zu mal
vielleicht ein Interview aus dem Rippenstein. Ach ja das hat jetzt irgendwie aufgrund des
seltenen Froschart länger gedauert oder wir haben hier Ressourcenengpässe an der Stelle
und ach guck mal hier ist jetzt wieder irgendwie Fachkräftemangel. Du musst ja ab und zu mal
ein paar Ausreden zurechtlegen aber ansonsten. Was macht da in Stuttgart 21 mittlerweile?
Also 21 ist übrigens das Jahr glaube wo das fertig werden sollte. Der ist bestimmt noch
nicht fertig oder? Bestimmt ist Stuttgart 31 mittlerweile. Wie macht man das eigentlich?
Im Dezember 2025 im Leben nichts. Das glaube ich nicht dass ich das noch sehe. Ihr müsst
euch mal vorstellen die bauen da dran jetzt. Also die haben guck mal die haben das 1994
vorgestellt und das sind Leute das muss ich auch in der Zunge zergehen lassen. 30 Jahre
vom Vorstellen bis zum geplanten Abschluss und das ist wahrscheinlich bis 2030 oder
35 dann fertig. 30 haben wir 40 Jahre. In der Zeit haben die China-Chinesen schon 5
Länder erobert und sind zum Mond geflohen und haben eine Mondstation gebaut bis der
Bahnhof fertig ist. Das ist echt der Wahnsinn. Ja der Rom wurde aber erbaut irgendwann mal
und erweitert und es hat funktioniert. Was ich ja dann noch zeigen muss ob der Kram aber
ordentlich funktioniert. Ich weiß nicht ob das alles so sinnvoll ist. Ich glaube das
wichtigste bei der Bahn ist dass du an den verantwortlichen Positionen Leute hast die
ein persönliches Interesse daran haben das ihren Job zu erledigen und dementsprechend
ja auch negative Konsequenzen fürchten müssen wenn sie es nicht machen. Einfach ein paar
Nordkoreaner holen das machen die Chinesen auch. Ich habe letztens einen Bericht darüber
gelesen dass viele durch den gestiegenen Wohlstand in China haben jetzt keinen Bock mehr lebensgefährliche
Menschen unwürdige Arbeiten auszuführen. Allerdings sind das Jobs die trotzdem gemacht
werden müssen also haben sie sich jetzt ein paar Nordkoreaner geholt die das für sie
erledigen. Also es geht immer noch weiter nach unten. Das auch die sollen gefälligst
selbst mit der Bahn fahren sehe ich genauso. Oh man. So Leute Bedgetime 22 Uhr 16 das ist
schon Bumer müde Bumer schlafen ist angesagt. Morgen fahre ich nach Frankfurt mal gucken
wie es läuft. Bestimmt gut naja mein Zug fällt ja schon mal aus habe ich gerade nachgeguckt
aber wenn ich das weiß ohne Scheiß mir ist das lieber ich weiß das jetzt schon kann ich
nach alternativen gucken. Ok Leute wir sehen uns bis denn machts gut.